Borgers, Alter, Borgers, Huge Borgers!
Kurze Klimaanlage resetten.
Die meinten nämlich das, wobei, ha, ne, stimmt.
Hier hat einfach die falsche Zeitzone eingestellt, ich wollte grad sagen, es stimmt hinten und
vorne nicht.
Heck, wait.
Nur gut, ehm, ist überhaupt schon irgendjemand da?
Ich glaube nicht.
Kann ich auch mal den Chat kurz refreschen, weil bei mir noch IAL dransteht, was überhaupt
nicht sein kann, wenn man in Science and Technology am Start ist.
Jetzt, der Krypto Tripler ist am Start, das ist ja die Kombination aus allem, was grad
angesagt ist.
Kryptowährung und Fußball-EM, das ist echt der optimale Name für 2021, Krypto Tripler.
Richtig Pog, nicht Pogchamp, Pogchamp, Alter.
Ist die Musiklautstärke okay?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Moin, ja, mal gucken.
Ich warte jetzt mal bis das Stream on ist, dann kann ich euch zeigen, was wir machen.
Jetzt geht's los, Klausur und was, was, ernsthaft?
Ihr schreibt Samstag, irgendwelche Prüfungen, was denn, in was denn, in was habt ihr Samstags
und was habt ihr da gemacht?
Jonasbomber97, hey Max, schaust du den Gameplay-Trailer von Battlefield heute im Stream, ist das nicht
erst morgen?
Das ist doch erst morgen, oder?
Ja.
Hier.
Morgen ist es erst, heute ist der 12., am 13. ist das.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, bis wann die NDA gilt, Zack, ich schau mal, dann kann ich euch
sagen, ob ich was im Stream zeigen kann oder nicht, ich schaue mal kurz, ich schaue mal
kurz.
Da muss ich die Mail von Freeman, der kann einen besten Namen von EA, also wenn man im
Bereich Freeman heißt, dann ist alles gut, okay, Makischi1, Dankeschön für PrimeSub,
okay, Trailer, NDA ist bis 13., also morgen, PDT, EDT, BST, AEST, CEST, meine Güte, können
die Leute nicht einfach die Zeits in UTC angeben und jeder weiß Bescheid, oder alternativ
in Sekunden seit 01.01.1970, ist mir egal, aber ich meine ernst, das kann doch nicht
sein, hier blickt doch keiner mehr durch, so, da steht NDA und Embargos, dann steht dann
da die Zeit, PDT, EDT, BST, AEST, CEST, meine Güte, okay, 16 Uhr, nee, 8.30 PM, das heißt
20.30 Uhr ist die NDA, nee, darf ich noch nichts sagen, alles klar, sehr gut, oh, ich
hab wieder eine VPN, VPN-Partnerschaftsanfrage bekommen, um was ging es, um den Battlefield
Gameplay-Trailer, ich hab wieder eine Anfrage bekommen, VPN-Werbepartnerschaft von, wie
heißen die hier, Privado-VPN, hab ich noch nie gehört, hab ich noch nie gehört, ah,
die kommen aus der Schweiz, exzellent, Kengi, Dankeschön für 10 Monate Subscription, die
kommen aus der Schweiz, ja, dann, passt ja, Affiliate-Programm, nee, nee, nee, lass mal,
lass mal, ich brauch kein VPN-Affiliate-Programm, alles klar, okay, auf geht's, also, machst
du eigentlich Beta-Testing auf deinem Private-Device, nee, nee, nee, das mach ich nicht, ich bin
in diesem Test-Flight-Programm für ein paar Apps drinne, aber das iOS-Beta-Test ich nicht,
sehe ich jetzt auch den Grund für mich nicht, ich verwende ja den Apple-Gramm gerade, dass
er eben funktioniert, und warum sollte ich dann da Beta testen, da kann ich auch noch
die 5 Tage oder so warten, wie lange ist das, oder 5 Wochen warten, bis das da rauskommt,
wie man das ausmacht, bisschen zu kühl gestellt, ich hab noch nicht viel mit Azure gemacht,
was kann man da mit alles machen, das ist so kompliziert, das kann ich jetzt nicht in
einem Satz alles sagen, also du kannst in Azure fast alles machen, was du willst, außer
Doppelpunkte in Dateien verwenden, das ist nicht so gut, hab ich euch das eigentlich
erzählt mit Doppelpunkten in den Dateien, das hab ich euch erzählt, glaub ich, dankeschön
für den Zap hier, Leona Bombald, wir hatten Glück gehabt, DGN Eric Poggers, wird das aufgenommen,
ich hab alle Wots online, ja übrigens, was witzig ist, also ich muss das hier ein bisschen
ausholen, Azure Functions, nee nicht Azure Functions, ich muss doch mal von vorne anfangen,
also jetzt noch mal hier zurückzukommen auf die Frage, du kannst damit unglaublich viel
machen, du kannst anfangen VMs zu hosten, das ist die einfachste Geschichte, du kannst
managen Datenbanken, managen Event Cues, managen hast du nicht gesehen nehmen, managen Files,
managen Plop Storage, managen alles mögliche, dann kannst du quasi Serverless Computing
Functions, also du musst dir das mal durchlesen, da gibt es auch ziemlich gute Einstiegs Tutorials,
ich hab ja auch keinen Plan davon so wirklich, muss ich sagen, aber wir machen auf der Arbeit
relativ viel mit Azure, deswegen komm ich da ab und zu mal in Berührung und muss mir
da mal ein bisschen mehr angucken, dass ich dann wieder Five Head bin, wenn es soweit
ist, ja, aber ich muss euch was lustiges erzählen und zwar, Support Ende Windows 10, was ist
mit Support Ende Windows 10, ok, dann bin ich mal gespannt, es gibt da noch gar kein
Nachfolger, das ist eine Microsoft Taktik, Alter, Support Ende verkünden ohne, dass
es Nachfolger gibt, was kommt denn danach, Cloud, Cloud, ey, wisst ihr was, ohne Scheiß,
wenn Microsoft sagt, es gibt kein neues Windows, also ich bin ja der Meinung, ich bin ja der
Meinung, Linux auf dem Desktop wird es nie geben, es sei denn, Microsoft würde jetzt
sagen, es gibt kein Windows mehr, es gibt nur noch irgendwie Cloud Featured und du hast
im Prinzip nur noch dein Monitor bei dir, dann sieht es was anderes, dann sieht es
anders aus, dann würde sich Linux auf dem Desktop wahrscheinlich durchsetzen und nicht
etwa weil es auf einmal so gut ist, sondern weil es Microsoft verkackt, ja, ok, Enddatum
von Windows 10, 14.
Oktober 2025, ja, ok, dann noch ein bisschen hin, die Version von Windows, ey, die sind
relativ einfach, das ist total einfach, das ist 2021, 2.
Halbjahr, also sprich, das gibt es noch nicht, wir müssten jetzt bei 21h1 sein gerade, also
die Windows Versionen sind tatsächlich easy, das ist immer das Jahr und das ist erstes
oder zweites Halbjahr, ich meine, das ist ein bisschen unorthodoxe, was, h2 gibt es
schon, ach stimmt, wir haben ja, wie, warum gibt es h2 schon, wie kann es 21h2 geben,
das kommt immer im Oktober oder so, Erbsupdate, ja gut, die haben Beta-Versionen von, das
ist doch nicht das zweite Halbjahr, das zweite Halbjahr gibt es seit 11 Tagen, du glaubst
du nicht, dass Microsoft so schnell da was rausbringt, das kommt meistens im Oktober
oder so, ja, das ist Beta dann wahrscheinlich, genau, also, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben,
genau, also, bevor wir uns jetzt hier in die Welt von Serverless Big Brain Azure Functions
begeben, muss ich ja noch mal was lustiges von der Arbeit erzählen und zwar, es kann
sein, dass ich das schon mal erzählt habe, wir haben bei uns relativ viele Mails, Terabyte-weise,
ich sage jetzt einfach mal was, so über den Daumen gepeilt, so 150 Terabyte-Mails, über
die letzten Jahre hat sich das angesammelt, Mails, also ganz klassisch Text-Mails, ja,
für den Außendienst, so, und das Ganze soll jetzt umgezogen werden auf Azure und jetzt
kommt der Hit, weil ich gerade gesagt habe, Azure macht ja fast alles und jetzt ist der
Hit, sie haben sich überlegt, hey, das Ganze muss umgezogen sein, so in 14 Tagen, in 14
Tagen muss das, muss das fertig sein, ja, so, und dann hat man gesagt, ok, wir machen,
wir machen jetzt einfach, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, pass auf, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt
der Hit, jetzt kommt der Hit, jetzt kommt der Hit, dann haben wir gesagt, na gut, das
einzige was man machen könnte ist, das einzige was man machen könnte ist, wir machen einfach,
wir machen einfach eine VM, schieben alles hoch und lassen dann unseren Mailserver einfach
dort in der VM laufen, so, dann kam das raus, hat man mal grob überschlagen, was würde das
Ganze mit SSDs kosten, Leute ratet mal, was das mit, geht man davon aus, 150 Terabyte-Storage
oder sagt einfach mal nur 100 Terabyte-Storage und VMs in Azure, die schnell genug sind,
also ihr müsst, ihr müsst nicht raten, aber wir sind so bei ungefähr 50.000 Euro, 50.000
Euro im Monat, das hat ihnen da nicht so gefallen, 50.000 Euro im Monat und, also mit, mit den
ganzen Ausstattungen, die man so braucht und das hat ihnen nicht gefallen, dass man 50.000
Euro im Monat braucht, das kann ich ja auch verstehen, ich meine, 50.000 Euro im Monat
ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel, also ihr könnt ungefähr, ihr könnt ungefähr ausrechnen,
wir haben das ja hier gemacht mit dem, mit dem Azure Price Calculator haben wir ja gemacht,
also, ja, ja, Microsoft ist sehr gut, hab ich oft zu tracken, okay, der ist wieder in einem
richtig, richtig schnell, ah, da sind wir, ne, kann man hier sagen, Virtual Machine hinzufügen,
ich zeige euch das mal im View, der ist übrigens richtiger Paints-Champ, der Calculator, ne,
dann kannst du sagen, Operating System Linux, Ubuntu, Jubandu, brauchen wir, wir brauchen
das Richtige, also wir brauchen, so, dann haben wir irgendwas hier, es ist eigentlich
vollkommen egal, Virtual Machines, Komplett, 24.7, so, und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt das
interessant, Standard SSD, 32, 60, ja, ich glaube, wir haben mit 2 oder 3 SSDs da irgendwie
kalkuliert mit 2, also wir sind bei 5.000 Dollar und da kommt natürlich ein bisschen
was dabei, weil die VM hier viel, viel zu klein ist, wir brauchen wahrscheinlich irgendwie
eher sowas da oder so in der Richtung, also, bezahlen wir 6.000 Euro im Monat, stimmt,
Region, ja, aber bei uns ist es noch teurer, Germany haben die, also, Germany West, Germany
West Central, ja, es kostet einfach, es kostet einfach noch ein bisschen, also 6.675 Dollar,
easy, easy as fuck, so, eine VM, eine, eine, eine, wir brauchen 10 oder so, zumindest
50.000 Euro plus im Monat, so, jetzt kommt Big Brain Move, Big Brain, Big Brain Move,
man könnte das Ganze hier auch nach Azure Files legen, Azure Files ist deutlich günstiger,
Azure Files ist quasi, man kann sich das so vorstellen, für Leute, die es jetzt nicht
so, das ist ein Windows Share in Azure, ein NFS oder ein Windows Share, so wie euer NAS,
ja, ihr bekommt dann, wie auf eurem NAS bekommt ihr quasi einen Ordner in Azure, da könnt
ihr euren Kram drauflegen, das ist deutlich günstiger, also, wenn das hier 70k im Monat
kostet, dann kostet das irgendwie dann nur, nur 15.000 Euro im Monat oder so, aber, jetzt
kommt der Witz, jetzt kommt der Witz, Azure NFS, also, das ist quasi Files Server, du
weißt, was rauskam, ja, ja, ich weiß, was du das heißt, NFS ist quasi so ein Windows
Share für Linux, so, und das erste Problem war, in Mails, so, in dem Format, wie die
eingestellt sind, standardmäßig, da sind Doppelpunkte in den Ordnern drinne, beziehungsweise
Doppelpunkte in den Dateien drinne, und als Azure NFS Preview noch, also, noch ganz am
Anfang Preview war, durfte man keine Doppelpunkte verwenden in den Dateien, das war natürlich
ein bisschen doof, also, das heißt, man konnte den Kram gar nicht hinlegen, halt ein bisschen
Paynes Champ, so, da haben wir uns hin und her überlegt, hin und, das hab ich euch, glaube
ich, das letzte Mal schon erzählt, ne, dann haben wir hin und her überlegt, was machen
wir jetzt, was machen wir jetzt, hat ein paar Workarounds, hat alles nicht funktioniert,
hat alles hin und vorne überhaupt nicht funktioniert, und irgendwann haben wir dann gesagt, okay,
wir machen jetzt einfach mal ein paar Performance-Tests, und dann festgestellt, dass Azure Files für
ziemlich viel so Random IOU mit kleinen Files einfach lahm as fuck ist, also brutalst lahm,
so von, so von, keine Ahnung, 2 MB die Sekunde lahm oder so, das ist halt unbenutzbar, das
konntest du komplett vergessen, so, und dann haben wir telefoniert mit einer Microsoft-Experte,
dreimal dürft ihr raten, was der Microsoft-Experte gesagt hat, der hat gesagt, das liegt nicht
an Microsoft Azure, das liegt daran, dass ihr das mit einem Linux-Client verwendet,
wir sollen das doch mal mit Windows testen, weil natürlich NFS unter Windows auf Azure
natürlich jede Menge viel, viel schneller ist, garantiert, garantiert viel schneller,
zumindest, also ich bin jetzt zu dem Schluss gekommen, wenn man große Dateimengen in Azure
ablegen will, dann ist das schlicht und ergreifend nicht der richtige Ort, es sei denn, man benutzt
Software, die eben direkt mit den Azure Apis reden kann, also sprich, was geht es, wenn
man Software hat, die direkt Azure Blob Storage oder irgendwie sowas lesen kann, das ist okay,
das mag sein, aber die klassische Art und Weise mit Filesystem in Azure ist einfach
teuer als fuck und kann es komplett vergessen, war das ein Marketing-Spezialist oder ein Technik-Spezialist,
ich glaube keins von beidem, was du kannst, was, Zia-Coin, habe ich noch nie gehört,
ist Zia-Coin irgendeine Kryptowährung mit Storage, die die Storage speichert, so also
ist halt ein bisschen problematisch, ist halt ein bisschen problematisch, du hast keine
Chance aktuell den Kram irgendwie, ja ich glaube es wird ein bisschen schwierig, DSGVO
konform und rechtskonform Außendienst-Mails in einem dezentralen Blockchain-Speicher zu
speichern, ich glaube das sind wir noch nicht bereit für sowas, was ist jetzt die Lösung
bei uns, wir haben noch keine, ich habe eine Lösung vorgeschlagen, ich habe eine Lösung
vorgeschlagen, die wollte aber keiner, ich habe gesagt wir fahren alle zum Saturn und
holen uns USB-Festplatten und stopseln sie wieder unten im Rechenzentrum an, das wollte
aber niemand, mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn wir in manchen, also ich glaube nicht,
dass wir komplett zurückbauen, das nicht, aber dass wir einige Sachen wieder zurückbauen
oder rauskommt, die lassen sich unglücklich in Asher hosten, wenn man sich auf Asher beschränkt
wohlgemerkt, dann wird es schwierig, ich habe vorgeschlagen wir können zu Hetzner gehen,
da hätte ich auch 20 Euro Startguthaben, Ausrufe zeige ich in Hetzner, wenn ihr auch
20 Euro Startguthaben haben wollt, aber das war vielleicht auch nicht der richtige Vorschlag,
warum kein Google Cloud, weil bei uns auf der Arbeit alles auf Asher ausgerichtet ist,
aber ich glaube mal, Google Cloud hat ähnliche Probleme, ja genau, kann man alles machen,
zumindest die ursprüngliche Variante hat nicht funktioniert, das ist das worauf ich
raus wollte, so eine genaue Lösung gibt es jetzt noch nicht, zumindest wir machen jetzt
Big Brain Asher Functions und zwar, was ich heute machen will ist, ne, so einfach ist
das nicht, einfach Call Storage, das wäre wirklich relativ easy, das kriegt man irgendwo
gelagert, es geht nicht nur um rechtssichere Aufbewahrung, das ist das eine, man braucht
da aus Gründen auch regelmäßig Zugriff drauf, zum Beispiel kann jemand im Außendienst
sagen, da gibt es dann so ein Web Interface, da kann man dann filtern, so nach dem Motto,
ich habe vor 5 Jahren an diesen Kunden E-Mails geschickt, dann drückt er auf den Suchenfeld
und dann kann er quasi seine Mails in den letzten 10 Jahren durchsuchen und das ist
halt ein bisschen doof, wenn das Call Storage ist, ne, ja mit Exchange ist tatsächlich
das, was die ganz gut supporten bei Microsoft, aber das kriegen wir ja nicht gebacken.
Dazu habe ich viel zu wenig Ahnung.
Ich habe übrigens letztens ein neues Excel, eine Excel IDE gesehen, passt mal auf, das
habe ich letztens auf Reddit gesehen, Query Storm Excel hieß das ganze, ja, eine SQLC
SHARP IDE in Excel, hat letztens irgendwie einer gepostet auf Reddit, im C-Sharp Subreddit,
Alter.
Das ist die Datenbank für Arme, wenn es keine richtige Datenbank tut, dann gibt es Excel.
Was sind die Vorteile, die Vorteile liegen ja auf der Hand, BWL-Kacknoobs können den
Gramm hier verwenden und Leute können dann ordentlich mit programmieren, übrigens ich
hatte letztens einen, der war besonders lost unter meinen YouTube-Commons, das muss ich
euch jetzt nochmal zeigen, bevor wir mit Azure anfangen, ich bin hier übrigens schon eingeloggt,
na, CACW, Stream, ACC, also Hacker-Mans sind bestimmt schon wieder alle drinnen glaube
ich, oder, Chat, schon alle eingeloggt bei mir auf dem Azure-Account, also ich habe explizit
einen Stream-Account gemacht, da stehe ich wieder die Hälfte liege, was wollte ich jetzt
sagen, genau, ich hatte letztens bei mir auf YouTube einen, der war richtig lost, das muss
ich euch jetzt echt mal zeigen, ich glaube das war hier, wo es darum ging, dass die Apple-Leute
nicht mehr aus dem Homeoffice raus wollten, der hier, der hier, richtig lost, das Kommentar,
an alle Leute, die Homeoffice toll finden, ihr müsst wissen, dass euer Job als erstes
wegrationalisiert wird, entweder braucht es euch eigentlich gar nicht, oder man ersetzt
euch gleich durch digitale Technologien, Homeoffice ist der erste Schritt zur Entlassung, glaubt
mir, das Marketing-Gewäsch eurer Vorgesetz dürft ihr also durchaus ernst nehmen, der
Kerl ist komplett lost, also wen schmeißen die zuerst raus, IT-Experten oder BWLer, die
vor Ort nichts anderes können als mieten und dumm Zeug labern, wer ist wohl als erstes
ersetzbar nach dieser Logik, das hab ich echt nicht verstanden, man hat nämlich bei uns
gesehen, dass Homeoffice Jahre, also jetzt eineinhalb Jahre lang, also in der IT hat
man das gesehen, Jahre lang ohne Probleme, eineinhalb Jahre zumindest, jetzt ohne Probleme
funktioniert hat, im ganzen BWL-Projektmanagement-Bereich, da eher weniger, da klingen es die Leute nämlich
öfters nicht hin, also die Logik, die sind komplett lost, die sind komplett lost as fuck
ey, vor allem IT wird durch Technologie ersetzt, das ist ja an sich schonmal widersprüchlich,
dass man in der IT im Homeoffice durch Technologie ersetzt wird, und wer kümmert sich dann um
die Technologie, die einen ersetzt, ich geh mal davon aus, dass das irgendein BWL-Mann
ist, der stinkig ist, dass er ins Büro fahren muss oder so, geh ich mal von aus jetzt einfach,
aber das ist richtig lost, richtig hardcore lost das ganze, okay, haben die denn Dark-Theme
irgendwo, ah, was ist das, ach nee hier, ah okay schon besser, schon besser, weil ich
wollt grad sagen, das ist ja nunmal ernsthaft das hässlichste Dark-Theme, was ich je gesehen
hab, alter, okay, also bevor wir anfangen, muss ich noch ein paar Sachen hier erzählen,
was wir im Chat, euch im Chat gesehen haben, tja, ja die Logik funktioniert überhaupt
nicht, Leute wenn ich irgendwas übersehen hab, etwa bloß in Chat, dann bin ich am Start,
okay, ich muss sagen, ich hab absolut keine Ahnung von Azure Functions, der Grund warum
ich das jetzt mache ist folgendes, das muss ich euch vielleicht, das muss ich euch vielleicht
auch noch mal kurz erklären und zwar, ich hab auf der Arbeit, ich muss mal meinem Chef
den Stream schicken, ob ich das nicht abrechnen kann danach, ich hab auf der Arbeit was programmiert
und zwar, das hab ich euch schonmal erzählt, unter der Haube ist es ein ferngesteuerter
Chrome, ja, es ist ein Chrome und ein bisschen Fernsteuerung, Skript dabei und der lockt
sich bei einem Webservice ein, klickt dort ein paar Häkchen an, drückt da ein paar Buttons
und lockt sich wieder aus, das ist alles, das ist alles was das Ganze macht, das ist
insofern aber ganz praktisch, dann muss es keiner mehr von Hand machen, so und ich hab
mir jetzt gedacht, ja, wir haben ja hier Cloud, großartige Cloud Strategie bei uns auf der
Arbeit am Start, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, warum mach ich denn dieses Programm nicht
einfach als Azure Functions oder als Azure Function, ich hab keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert,
das einzige Azure Function was ich mit Azure Functions bisher mal zu tun hatte ist, ich
hab mir ein Tutorial auf YouTube angeguckt, das ist alles, also, das was wir heute mal
probieren werden ist folgendes, der Kommentar von, ach ernsthaft, der Kommentar von YouTube
war übrigens der Geschäftsführer eines Architekturbüros, ja gut, für den trifft
das ja auch zu was er geschrieben hat, aber für uns trifft das nicht zu, wetten, wetten
der Typ lässt seine IT Leute nicht im Homeoffice arbeiten, weil er der Meinung ist, das geht
nicht, die sollen gefälligst vor Ort am Start sein, glaubst du das neue BF könnte
dein Lieblingsbattlefield werden, ich hab das noch nicht gespielt, da kann ich nichts
zu sagen, keine Ahnung, das kann ich dir erst sagen, wenn ich das mal zumindest angespielt
hab, bisher sieht man einen Cinematic Trailer ohne das aus dem man viel ableiten kann,
übrigens wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe, ich hab ja hochgeladen mit dem Lost so den
Talk zum neuen Battlefield, bei Azure Function muss man jeden Aufruf der Funktion bezahlen,
nee, nee, nee, nee, siehst du gleich, da sind relativ viele Aufrufe free, ich hab ja
den Talk mit dem Lost hochgeladen bei mir auf YouTube und da haben ganz viele Leute
geschrieben, oh Battlefield ist verloren, so nach dem Otto Battlefield kann ich mir
nicht geben, diese ganzen Specialist Geschiss, das hat ja mit Battlefield überhaupt nichts
zu tun, ich glaube die Leute missverstehen die Specialists in Battlefield 6 oder Battlefield
2042, die denken an Operator aus Rainbow Six, aber das ist es gar nicht, im Prinzip ist,
da muss ich glaube ich nochmal ein extra Video zu aufnehmen, das ist im Prinzip gar kein
Unterschied zu bisher, bisher konntest du in Battlefield Sturmsoldat auswählen und
du konntest dann auswählen Medikit oder Smoke Granatenwerfer oder was auch immer,
also du konntest ja, du hast Medic ausgewählt und dann hast du in dem Menü dein Gadget
ausgewählt, mehr sind die Specialists gar nicht, die Specialists sind quasi, dieses
Menü wähle dann Primary Gadget aus, das ist alles, im Prinzip ist das eigentlich die
gleiche Mechanik wie bisher, nur dass man jetzt Skins verkaufen kann, eigentlich richtig
Big Brain, deswegen verstehe ich die Aufregung gar nicht, das ist so gut wie kein Unterschied
zu vorher, muss man nicht verstehen, wann kommt das nächste Map Video, weiß ich auch
nicht, müssen wir mal gucken, so ok, Big Brain Leute, ich hab mir, ich hab mir extra
einen Account angelegt, hier für den Stream, dass ich nichts leake und da habe ich mein
Payment Profil hinterlegt, das heißt wenn ich jetzt nicht aufpasse, habe ich morgen
10.000€ Schulden oder so, na gut ich glaube es wird schwierig 10.000€ Schulden zu machen
mit Azure Function, wenn ich mich nicht rekursiv selbst aufrufe, hey Leute wie schnell lernt
man Windows Server Active Directory zu verstehen und zu benutzen, Assistent und Wizard durchklicken
kann man innerhalb von 10 Minuten lernen, ich glaube in der Tiefe verstehen tun das vielleicht
5 Leute auf der Welt, weil das Microsoft Logik ist, die kannst du eigentlich gar nicht
verstehen, jetzt können sich die Sniper ihre Munition selbst mitnehmen, ja das geht glaube
ich, ok auf gehts, also von der Idee her, ich muss mal kurz hier die Hilfeseite aufmachen,
Azure Functions, Azure Functions.NET 5, ihh warum krieg ich den Artikel auf Deutsch
vorgeschlagen, Kack Wade, auf Englisch und jetzt das allerwichtigste, hab ich das hier
nicht schon auf, doch ich hab es doch schon auf, da hab ich es doch, also ich versuchte
es jetzt mal zu erklären, was Azure Functions sind als jemand der Azure Functions noch nie
verwendet hat, also der Unterschied zu beispielsweise in AVM ist folgender, in AVM hast du ein vollständiges
Betriebssystem laufen, vollständiges Linux laufen, wo da eine Anwendung drin läuft die
Software ausführt, so bei Serverless Functions, Serverless ist der bescheuertste Name überhaupt,
letztendlich gibt es da genauso Server wie überall anders auch, nur dass du dich nicht
darum kümmern musst, also Serverless ist eigentlich eine absolut hirnverbrannte Bezeichnung
auf die bloß irgendwelche Marketing Stunks Leute kommen können, so und in Azure Functions
hinterlegst du quasi dein Source Code, sagst wie der getriggert werden soll und dann wird
er ausgeführt, ohne dass du dich um Server kümmern musst, ohne dass du dich irgendwie
um Betriebssystem Updates kümmern musst oder um Library Updates oder um irgendwelche
Dinge, wobei Library Updates musst du dich glaube ich sonst, muss ich glaube ich noch
darum kümmern, zumindest kannst du da relativ easy voneinander getrennte Funktionalität
ohne großartige Infrastruktur drum herum ausführen lassen, deswegen ist das zur Zeit relativ
beliebt, weil das ist im Prinzip das was diesem Cloud Gedanken am nächsten kommt,
also sprich du benutzt einen Service, wo dein Code drauf läuft, du musst dich nicht mehr
wirklich drum kümmern und du bezahlst nur das was du benutzt, das mit diesem bezahlst
nur was du benutzt ist allerdings auch bei Cloud so eine kleine Falle, weil wenn du viel
benutzt, ist es in der Regel tatsächlich immer noch günstiger man stellt sich selbst
den Server hin, also da muss man gucken, also das Cloud jetzt irgendwie gerade wenn du viel
damit machst billiger ist als den eigenen Server zu verwalten habe ich immer noch so
meine Zweifel.
Ab letzte Woche habe ich in einem Betrieb gesagt, dass ich nach der Ausbildung nicht
bleiben werde, was denkst du ist eine realistische Gehaltsvorstellung für fachinformatische
Anwendungsentwicklung, der im Web Entwicklungsbereich gelernt habe, also es gab jetzt vor ein paar
Tagen bei Heise glaube ich wieder einen aktuellen Gehaltsbericht, da kannst du mal gucken,
ich glaube irgendwo hier, letztens irgendwas gesehen.
Und das kann man so gar nicht beantworten, weil es hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab,
in welcher Branche du aktiv bist und wo in Deutschland du aktiv bist, also bis jetzt
zum Beispiel in Frankfurt, da kriegst du mit Sicherheit mehr als irgendwo im Osten auf
dem Land oder so, also das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an wo du bist und das allerwichtigste
ist nach wie vor halt ob du was kannst, was gefragt ist, kannst du zum Beispiel Kobold,
dann reißen sie sich hier die Beine für dich aus, oder was, ab ab alter, ne das kann
man so pauschal nicht sagen, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen, Webkobold, genau
jetzt probieren wir das ganze mal, Leute ich habe absolut, null ist legit, ich habe absolut
keine Ahnung davon wie das funktioniert, wie man Azure Functions macht, wirklich null,
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, also gibt es hier sowas wie zu Insta, ich habe mir schon
ein Ordner gemacht, da ist aber nichts drin, Azure, was gibt es im Package Manager nach
zu Azure, Azure CLI, das kenne ich, das kenne ich von der Arbeit, das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich,
was ist es wenn ich nach Functions suche, was ist ab ab, das ist die Programmiersprache
von SAP, das willst du nicht, Azure Functions Core Tools Bin, ok, also was braucht man,
was braucht man installiert, lass mal hier kurz gucken, Azure Account habe ich,.NET5
habe ich installiert, ok vielleicht sollte ich mal ein Package Update machen wo wir gerade
dabei sind, oh es gibt ein paar Updates, warum ich mit 48 FPS streame, das ist ganz einfach,
weil 48 FPS flüssiger ist als 30 und nicht so viel Bandbreite beziehungsweise mehr Bandbreite
übrig ist für jedes einzelne Build als bei 60, also ist 48 der optimale Kompromiss
für Streams eigentlich, das ist ja der Grund warum der Hobbit auch in 48 FPS gedreht wurde,
die wussten das einfach schon, 60 FPS sind die richtigen, 60 FPS sind eigentlich die
richtigen Kacknoobs, 30 sind die Leute die sich es nicht besser leisten können, 60 sind
die richtigen Kacknoobs und alles 144 FPS plus ist Big Brain, außer für Streams da
sind 48 optimal, ey Snap, was update denn da alles, ich mach mal kurz Updates, ich weiß
nicht was ich da alles für, ok wir kriegen auch.NET ab, ey Electron wird ja immer schlimmer,
erst Snap und jetzt Electron auch noch, aber auch nur weil wir nicht mehr, doch ich könnte
mit mehr Bandbreite streamen auf Twitch, das Problem ist wenn ich mit mehr Bandbreite auf
Twitch streame, dass die Leute dann nicht zugucken können, weil wir in Deutschland
so tolles Internet haben, also ich streame aktuell mit 4900 MBit, ich gebe manchmal bei
Gaming Sachen rauf auf 6,9 oder 7,9, das Problem ist so dass manche Leute nicht gucken können,
genau deswegen haben auch viele 936p, Microsoft Windows 10 Teaser, ne ich hab nur gelesen
dass Windows 10 Support Ende verkündet wurde, hast du einen Link, Windows 10 Teaser, Windows
11, Windows 11, Trailer zum neuen Windows, oops, wegen welchen Gründen konntest du das
gerade nicht rüber kopieren, ah Restart Firefox, ok ist gut, exellent, hab ich es nicht noch
letztes Jahr gesagt, es wäre eigentlich verschenkt wenn Microsoft nicht bald mal ein neues Windows
10 rausbringen, achso, ok es ist 11 Minuten lang, kann doch sein, wird ja auch mal Zeit,
so wir haben geupdatet wunderbar, alter was will der hier denn alles updaten, ich sollte
es vielleicht öfters mal machen, komm her, aber gerade ein aktuelles Wishl Studio Code
sollte ich für das ganze Azure Zeug schon verwenden, also mal durchlesen, also ich hab
ein aktuelles.NET installiert, das passt, ich brauch was, Azure Functions Core Tools,
Azure CLI, Wishl Studio Code, die C-Sharp und die Azure Functions Extention, kann man
es auch mit, ich will es mit, nee ich will es nicht, ich will es mit Command Line machen,
viel besser, ah yes, Leute wie wollen wir es machen, wollen wir es mit Wishl Studio
Code machen, clicky clicky oder wollen wir die Hardcore Hacker Man Command Line machen,
also programmieren tun wir das eh dann in einem Editor, aber das einrichten, wir können
ja beides machen, CLI ok, exellent, wir machen beides, wir machen erstmal Wishl Studio Code,
weil ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, kann euch das auch erklären, ich hab die Erfahrung
gemacht, dass die Tutorials von Microsoft, die sich hier veröffentlicht auf ihrem Blog,
eigentlich ganz ok sind, aber im Detail sind diese Tutorials immer kacke, weil die schreiben
was, entweder absichtlich falsch, keine Ahnung, oder manchmal stimmen die Sachen nicht, die
haben dann falsche Menüs, die man machen muss oder Parfeele, Optionen, die es nicht gibt
oder was auch immer und ich hab gemerkt, dass diese Tutorials noch am ehesten funktionieren,
wenn man sie mit Wishl Studio Code macht, ich muss das mal hier übrigens gerade auf
Tag machen, so ok, wie gehts dann weiter, create local functions project, das heißt
man muss da einloggen, ah ich muss mich erstmal einloggen, ok, ja das passt, kann ich ja dann
machen, muss ich nochmal die ganzen Mist eintippen, so hat er jetzt geupdatet, ey mein Betriebssystem
ist aktuell, Hogwarts, Alter, huge, erstmal ne Runde entspannen, ok genug, also auf gehts,
was muss ich installieren, Asher Function Core Tools und Asher CLI, Asher CLI, krieg
ich, wie macht man das, du startest das hier, das ist irgendein Pearlscript glaube ich
unter der Haube, das musst du nachinstallieren, es gibt es aber nicht überall im Package
Manager, kannst du aber einfach runterladen, ist nix, das ist irgendwie 20 Jahre alt oder
so, so Asher CLI, da ist es, Leute ich hab mal ne Frage an euch, für die richtigen
Asher Hackermans, sollte man Asher CLI über den Package Manager installieren oder über
irgendwelche Microsoft Geschichten, gibt es das in Pacman, ja das ist ja quasi Pacman,
also haben die da irgendwie den eigenen Updater und Installer oder ist Package Manager am
besten, ich installiere mal mal Package Manager, ok unter der Haube ist das irgendein Python
Ding würde ich sagen, Hallo, Windows Alter, ah ne ist ja gar kein Windows, ist Firefox
und Linux, so erstmal den Grams hier installieren, dann haben wir Asher CLI, lass mal gucken,
was brauchen wir denn sonst noch, Asher Function Core Tools, ok, wie Installing, ne, kann ich
nicht machen, ich hab kein Ubuntu, ok wie installiert man diesen Krempel, Download Tip,
ist ernsthaft, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein, Ubuntu Docker Container benutzen, ja
gibt es das nicht, kann man das runterladen, ach hier NPM, ja dann, da installiere ich es
mit NPM, einfach NPM, was ist ein Ubuntu Docker Container, also erstmal müssen wir uns alle
daran gewöhnen, dass man das ordentlich ausspricht, weil die korrekte Aussprache ist ja eindeutig
Jubantu, das wissen wir ja, auch wenn Nelson Mandela Ubuntu sagt, aber der hat bekanntlich
aber überhaupt keine Ahnung davon wie man Afrikanisch spricht, also korrekt ist Jubantu,
was ist ein Ubuntu Docker Container, wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten, das ist alles außer
den Kernel genommen, in ein Image gepackt und eine Sandbox drumherum gemacht, das ist
quasi ein Ubuntu, was ich unter anderen Betriebssystemen laufen lassen kann als unter Ubuntu, ja, das
kommt drauf an, was du machst, also wenn du Form Upload machst, dann brauchst du ASP.NET
Core I-Form-File, ist es glaube ich, das brauchst du und das hat, das ist das, was du haben
Bild, dann Multipart Streaming, das ist das hier, das brauchst du, I-Form-File, das hat
doch auch Progress irgendwie oder, I-Form-File-Progress, das willst du haben hier, das willst du machen,
das, das, was, das, was hier, was ist das, what the fuck, ok dann ist es doch nicht so
einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe, ok ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie
es geht, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, das ist relativ einfach, ich meine, du kannst,
du kannst die einfachste Variante machen, was du machen kannst ist, du nimmst den Header,
Content Length und guckst dann, guckst dann, wie viel vom Body eingelesen ist, aber ganz
ehrlich, ich so aus dem Kopf kann ich dir auch nicht sagen, ok wir haben Azure CLI installiert,
das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier ATS, jawoll, ATS ist am Start, da muss ich mir jetzt erstmal
einloggen wahrscheinlich, so dann muss ich NPM Azure Functions Core Tools installieren,
by the way, du kannst auch beim Upload im Client das ganze einfach nur simulieren,
also du brauchst das eigentlich, also wenn du es nicht unbedingt Server-seitig machen
willst, dann würde ich es auch tatsächlich nicht Server-seitig machen, ich mache eigentlich
Upload-Progress nie Server-seitig mit Rückmeldung an Client, also das reicht, das reicht voll
und ganz, das was Colorforce sagt, einfach auf dem Client messen, wie weit der Upload
ist, das kannst du ja machen, kannst du ja, weiß ich, ob es mit Fetch geht, aber im Zweifel
vielleicht geht mit dem, was unter Fetch drunter, du brauchst doch nicht mal eine Fake-Progress-Bar,
du kannst eine richtig echte Progress-Bar machen, du weißt wie groß die Datei ist und
du siehst, du siehst wie weit der Upload ist, wenn du hoch lädst, ich glaube mit Fetch
geht es nicht direkt, mit Axios geht es wahrscheinlich, ansonsten musst du ein xhr-la-request-objekt
verwenden, das was unter Fetch drunter ist, so, also, was muss ich jetzt machen hier,
Azure Functions Core Tools, was genau macht Unsaved Perm True, das sieht so ein bisschen
nach MonkaS aus, will ich das wirklich ausführen, Azure Functions Unsaved Permission True, will
man das, ach komm, bam, wir wollen das, oh nein, ach so, sudo, ja klar, natürlich auch
noch als Root, ja was denn sonst, die passende Musik auch im Hintergrund gerade, äh, warum
geht das nicht, easy, das war es jetzt oder was, kann ich jetzt Funk machen, ah wunderbar,
Kunst, ok, wir haben Azure Functions CLI installiert, was brauchen wir dann sonst noch, Visual Studio
Code, Hammer C Sharp Extension, die Azure Functions Extension brauche ich noch, ok, die habe ich
natürlich noch nicht, warte mal, hier Visual Studio Code auf, zack, oh was ist das, das
ist neu, do you trust, hallo hier sind überhaupt keine Dateien drinne, ja ich truste nichts,
alles klar, gut, perfekt, erstmal getrusted, so Azure Functions installieren, ich hoffe
es ist das richtige, ja Microsoft, erstmal Staatsroyale herunterladen, ok, und jetzt,
und jetzt, Azure, bam, da sind wir, ok, kann man das irgendwie größer machen, ich glaube
ich, so, ok, ok, create a local function project, Office, da gibt es bestimmt jede Menge hier,
die das können, meinst du, du kannst ein Programm machen, das deine IP oder Passwort für den
Stream schwärzt, ne, was man machen könnte ist Browser, Browser Extensions, die das machen,
das gibt es bestimmt schon, es gibt bestimmt schon Browser Extensions, die gewisse Sachen
heiden, falls es doch mal geleakt werden sollte, das gibt es bestimmt, ansonsten müsste man
ja auf jedes Bild OCR anwenden und hoffen du erkennst, das klappt nicht, so also was
sollen wir denn jetzt machen hier, create a local function project, choose Azure Icon
in the activity bar, select create new project, ok, ja, in dem Ordner wo ich drinne bin ist
ok, C Sharp,.NET 5, select a template, Timer, Timer klingt gut, Timer, Name, Qt, Chat, Chat,
Provide a Namespace, ok, wir brauchen ein Namespace, wie nennen wir den, Switch, ne,
wir machen jetzt den, wir machen jetzt den Warzone Cancer Clan Tag Functions, obbei
ne, das ist bestimmt schon belegt, das muss bestimmt Unix sein, wir machen einfach Namespace
IAYA, IAYA.Qt, sehr gut, oh Gott, CronSynTags, wait a minute, was bedeutet die CronSynTags
alle 5 Minuten, ist das alle 5 Minuten, ich kann mir CronSynTags nie merken, wer will
alle 5 Minuten, ich will jede Minute haben, oh Invalid, was ist jetzt valid, ich lass
einfach mal, ich lass einfach mal das was da drin steht, in order to debug you must select
a storage account for internal use by Azure Function Runtime, da muss ich mich vorher
einloggen, sign in to Azure, ok Leute, ich mach euch mal kurz aus, ich hab keine Ahnung
was das einblendet, wenn ich mich sign inne, ich trau da Sache nicht, you can close the
page, wie das wars jetzt schon, ok ich hab nix gesagt, war total easy, was soll das eigentlich
werden, ich erstell ne, ich guck mir Azure Functions an und dann guck ich ob ich dann
irgendwie ne Chrome Automatisierung drin laufen lassen kann, ok ich klick jetzt einfach mal
den Editor weiter durch, was das ein, das ist CronSynTags, das bedeutet alle 5 Minuten,
CronSynTags, CronTabGuru guck, der CronTabGuru sagt, was für ein Ding, ich dachte das bedeutet
alle 5 Minuten, was, ich versteh noch nicht mal was ich sagen möchte, da braucht man
mehr Subs, dass man das versteht, das ist Microsoft CronExtension, ok select storage
account, das weiß ich von der Arbeit, das ist ganz sinnvoll die Dinge ordentlich zu
benennen, die nennen wir, die nennen wir, keine Ahnung, Chat, aber man darf keine Unterstriche
machen, Chat Functions, Resource Group, ja mach einfach, wir wollen nach Germany West,
was hast du, was soll einem das jetzt sagen, was genau meint das jetzt, what the fuck, aber
komm mal, ok, ok, ok, ok, ja, ich leg jetzt hier, hat er den storage account jetzt angelegt,
ne der hat den storage account gerade angelegt, na toll, ok dann erstelle ich mal von Hand
ein, create storage account, Chat Functions in Germany, ach das ging ja hier nicht, doch
das ging, schon gesehen Germany, Standard, das muss nicht, ganz ehrlich, das muss nicht
geo redundant sein, ich erstelle das jetzt einfach mal, wenn ich morgen Abend bin dann
hab ich Pech, wer übrigens denkt, dass Asher schnell ist, der fühlt sich öfters mal je
zu, das ist echt schrecklich, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Okay, wir machen das einfach nochmal.
Okay, 0W.
Muss das eigentlich Unix sein?
It must be Unix across all chat accounts.
0W, 0W, 1, 2, 3, perfekt.
Review and create.
Create.
Damn.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, eindeutig viel zu easy.
Jetzt habe ich US gewählt.
Nein.
Na gut, ich werde es überleben.
Jetzt ist es halt in US.
Hell yeah, Kikona.
Okay.
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was hier jetzt passiert ist.
Was soll ich denn jetzt hier weitermachen?
Okay, Functions, Functions, Functions.
Run locally, press F5.
Okay, hier, nee, Moment.
Run the function locally.
Ich habe da noch gar keine Funktion angelegt, oder?
Habe ich noch eine Funktion angelegt?
Ich habe da noch gar keine Funktion angelegt.
Okay, ähm, RIP, erst mal wieder löschen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da gemacht habe, wir machen das jetzt einfach nochmal
neu.
Okay, okay, Azure, create new project, fun, C sharp,.NET 5, Timer Trigger, ich bleibe
jetzt mal bei den Standard Dingern, das Ding heißt jetzt Timer Trigger 1 und es heißt
Company Punkt Function, meinetwegen und auch alles okay.
Okay, select storage account, design into Azure.
What the fuck, habe ich doch gerade schon gemacht.
Microsoft war wieder R.
Okay, ach guck mal, jetzt kann ich den hier auswählen, 0W, 0W, 0W, 1, 2, 3, den wollte
ich schon immer auswählen, perfekt.
Creating new Timer Trigger, aha, yes, C sharp Extensions installieren.
Warum nicht Hetzner, Hetzner Functions gibt das noch nicht.
Sollte es Hetzner Functions mal geben, dann verwende ich die auch.
So, okay, jetzt habe ich meine erste Azure Function angelegt, jetzt ist der große Preisfrage,
kann ich den Kram mit Visual Studio Code die Azure Geschichten machen und den Rest mit
sagen wir mal Rider programmieren, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, weil der Gelegenheit gerade
mal gucken, ob ich neue Rider Version brauche, nee, Go Land haben wir schon Rider.
Testen wir das mal, weil ich habe keinen Bock auf C sharp in Visual Studio Code, das ist
mir eindeutig zu nervig.
Okay, wir müssen nach Max, Repos, Func, Func, Func, Bäm, ja Trust und Open, klar, was sonst,
Trust und Microsoft, total.
So, kann man jetzt hier programmieren in Rider und den ganzen anderen Management Kram über
Visual Studio Code machen, das wäre natürlich noch viel nicer, sehr, sehr nice wäre das,
poggers nice.
Zeigt Azure eigentlich mehr Präsentationen und so im Vergleich zu AWS, hä, was meinst
du?
So, okay, jetzt habe ich hier eine Azure Function und was mache ich damit jetzt, die ist ja noch
nicht in Azure, Run Locally, okay, das muss ich in Visual Studio Code machen, einfach
F5 drücken, drücke jetzt einfach mal F5, wie das war, okay, das ist jetzt erstaunlicherweise
ziemlich einfach, ich habe schon gedacht, das ist zu einfach, das war mir schon klar,
dass das zu einfach ist, ich habe doch, Alter, ich habe alles installiert, was ihr wollt,
Microsoft,.NET 5, das da, das da, ich habe alles installiert, was ihr wolltet, warum
geht das denn nicht, it was not possible to find any compatible framework, 3.1, was, warum
soll ich 3.1 installieren, wenn die sagen, ich brauche 5.0, versteht die Logik irgendjemand,
Template in falscher Version geladen, ich habe gerade den Kram frisch installiert, ne,
so, also wenn ihr keine Ahnung habt, was Microsoft da wieder macht, dann einfach auf GitHub nach
Fehlersuchen, Azure, was ist denn hier, Bam, Azure Tools, Azure, nope, geh mal in die Pro
Datei und schau danach, okay, target framework.NET 5, Azure Functions v3, warum will das
Ding 3.1 haben, Azure Functions, ah, guck mal da, ich bin nicht der einzige, ich bin
nicht der einzige, der das Problem hat, kann man nicht Serverless dafür benutzen, das ist
Serverless, Max wie hieß, heißt nochmal die Seite, wo ich Nudeln bestellt hab, la, Lida,
du meinst die mit dem tollen Onlineshop, der richtig 2.0, Web 4.0 aussieht, Pasta, ja,
da kannst du, die Spaghetti sind richtig nice, Fusilli sind richtig nice, Regatoni sind richtig
nice bei denen und dann hatte ich so welche, die sahen aus wie Regatoni bloß auf der einen
Seite zu und rund, also sahen sie eigentlich nicht aus wie Regatoni, da weiß ich aber
nicht welche das waren, aber die Spaghetti sind richtig gut, so sehen die aus, die sind
auch viel fetter als die anderen Spaghetti, nein das kostet nicht 17 Euro, das sind 6
Packchen für 14 Euro, also du bekommst 6 mal 500 Gramm, also sprich 500 Gramm kosten
2,35 Euro, ich mein das ist immerhin auch noch teuer, beim Lidl kosten die 35 Cent
oder sowas, aber das ist wirklich, dies ist wirklich gut, billig ist es nett, das stimmt
schon, aber das schmeckt wirklich gut, wenn ihr mal zu viel Geld habt, bestellt ihr euch
für 138 Euro, das große Fest beginnt, 128 Euro Gönnung, 138, Vorspeise, das ist echt
gut, also was ist denn jetzt das Problem, ja genau das gleiche Problem habe ich auch,
ja genau, so habe ich doch gemacht, Power Shell, die wollen jetzt nicht eigentlich mit
die Power Shell Shit ausführen, by the way, kann mir mal irgendjemand erklären warum
diese Microsoft Anleitungen immer, und ich meine wirklich immer so sind, dass sie nicht
funktionieren, ich glaube ich habe jetzt, und das ist jetzt keine Übertreibung, ich glaube
ich habe noch nicht eine Microsoft Anleitung von diesen Dingern hier gemacht, die einfach
funktioniert haben, das ist das was ich meine, ich mache es mit Visual Studio Code, weil
die noch am ehesten funktionieren, ich hatte noch nicht eine Anleitung von Microsoft bei
diesem ganzen Scheiß, das irgendwie funktioniert hat, weil die kein Mensch aktualisiert, das
ist von das ist Kokona Zeitrechnung dritter, fünfter, das ist gar nicht so lange her,
sogar die Microsoft Doku Grills haben das aktualisiert, da kann doch nichts mal schief
gehen, das ist ein Running Gag bei denen intern, das kann sein, ja, ok, also was ist denn jetzt
dieses Problem, zeige ich mal her, yes, App Azure need to have five enabled, was, ok,
ich suche jetzt einfach mal danach, ok, six issues, bam, was für ein OS, das ist Manjaro
mit I3 als Winner, guck mal hier, ich bin nicht der einzige, das Problem, Bild failed,
was not found, why new Azure Functions for.NET 5 has dependencies, ja, das frage ich
mich auch, das ergibt doch keinen Sinn, ich muss explizit.NET 5 auswählen, warum brauche
ich eine.NET 3.1 Dependency, der hat genau das gleiche Problem hier wie ich, guck genau
das gleiche Problem, das ist eben ein Dude von Microsoft oder, ja, while targeting Azure
Functions for.NET 3.1, wo ist denn die Logik dahinter, warum mache ich eine Funktion für
.NET 5, aber ich brauche da noch 3.1, das ist zu Elevenhead von Microsoft wieder, das
soll ich adden, ich weiß noch nicht mal wo, known issues and limitations, alter, ok, ok,
also man muss auch für.NET 5 das 3.1 SDK installieren, hä, verstehe ich nicht, thanks
for reporting, vor allem warum closen die das wieder, by the way, wiki is a typo, ja,
das ist falsch, der Slash muss nicht hinten hin, der Slash muss vorne hin, guck mal wie
sie es jetzt editiert haben, guck mal wie sie es jetzt editiert haben, oh, es tut weh,
welcher 3.1 hat man bei Microsoft, hat das denn jetzt wieder gemacht, das ist ja wirklich
eytime, alter, sprich, am Anfang hatten sie es so, dann hat irgendeiner auf GitHub gemackert,
da fehlt vorne den Slash, also haben sie den Slash vorne hin gemacht, aber den Slash,
da sieht man mal wie es bei Microsoft so ist, da sieht man mal wie es bei Microsoft so ist,
es kochen alle nur mit Wasser, das wirkt von außen immer so, als würden bei Microsoft
nur kompetente Leute arbeiten, ja, oder meinetwegen auch bei Google oder sonst wie, aber das ist
nicht so, die haben auch keinen Plan, was sie machen, weil der Typ, der diese Seite
aktualisiert hat, das war auch noch er, der die Seite aktualisiert hat, guck mal hier,
ok, wer ist das, wer hat es verkackt, er hier, Fabio, was ist er denn, weiß man nicht, excellent,
alter, hat er gut gemacht, ok, was ist denn jetzt die Lösung davon eigentlich, ich installiere
jetzt einfach 3.1 oder was, was ist die Lösung dafür, die gehen aus, dass 3.1 schon installiert
ist, aber warum, wenn ich die.NET 5 installiert habe, ok, wir installieren jetzt noch eine
.NET 3, 1 zusätzlich, das geht ja nicht so einfach, ich habe mit dem Package Manager
bestimmt keine 3.1, ach doch, guck mal da, ich habe sogar noch ein 3.1er SDK hier, easy,
ja dann, Package Manager FTW, alter, perfekt,.NET List SDKs, 3.1, 3.5, 5.0, ja sehr schön,
ok das heißt, was muss ich jetzt machen, nochmal F5 drücken, gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert,
ah, ah yes, exquisite, jetzt läuft es, so und jetzt sollte alle 5 Minuten erscheinen,
ich habe jetzt den Text, wenn ich es richtig mache, gibt es eine Möglichkeit, Moment, Azure
Functions Local Start Once, irgendwie sowas, Fabio war vorher Produkt Manager bei Oracle,
der kann bestimmt ABAP programmieren, er sieht so aus, wie man der ABAP programmieren kann,
code is simplest way to run a timer locally once, genau das will ich machen, das will
ich machen, ich will nicht immer 5 Minuten warten um mein Code auszuprobieren, das soll
die Lokal einmal laufen lassen, ernsthaft, in welche Microsoft Hölle bin ich denn heute
wieder hinabgestiegen, wenn ich mir sowas angucke, da kann ich das ja auch gleich in
C++ programmieren, wo bin ich denn hier wieder gelandet heute, ok, run on startup gleich
true, run on startup, 0w, true, jetzt brechen wir das ab, starten es nochmal neu und gucken
ob es jetzt runnt, wusste gar nicht, dass es so Makro Zeug in CSC Sharp gibt, das ist
gar kein Makro Zeug, das ist ein bisschen Compiler Magic, also du kannst damit keine
Template Geschichten machen oder sowas, und Makro mäßig wie in C gibt es auch nicht,
das ist wirklich nur ganz rudimentär, ja und jetzt, run once, ich sehe da nichts, run
once, raucht ja vielleicht noch ein bisschen, OS Manjaro mit E3, eigentlich sollte das jetzt
triggern, run once, und dann sollte er einmal diesen Text hier ausgeben, macht er aber nicht,
warum macht er das nicht, ok dann stellen wir es doch mal auf jede Minute ein, run once
raucht axis ngo once, run once torch, run once, ok, so tun wir es und dann momen wir
Azure deployen ich mache mal ein bisschen bisschen bessere Ausgabe dass man ja dass man hier auch was erkennt
logger log information
So
Das erkennt man wenigstens
Weil wir können wir können ja ich sehe schon die ersten leute max warum hast du keine schleife können auch eine schleife drum machen
Zehn mal den kram jetzt hier
Agile as fuck ja finde ich auch ok und jetzt führen wir das ganze noch mal aus
Alle hier restart ok das das das funktioniert alles und nicht so richtig
Ah ja ok da ist alles klar so und jetzt werden wir das mal nach azure deployen und gucken ob es da prinzipiell läuft
Bevor ich weitermache
Das das macht mich schon wieder fertig warum musste ich das 3.1 SDK installieren wenn ich doch ein dotnet 5 programm laufen lassen will
Verstehe ich nicht es ist microsoft logik die kann ich einfach nicht nachvollziehen ok
Alles klar also wie deployt man das jetzt was sagt da hier das da habe ich gemacht habe ich gemacht
Ich hätte auch sagen können execute function now ok vielleicht vielleicht hätte man das tutorial doch noch weiterlesen sollen
Ok sign in to azure das habe ich schon gemacht publish project das project mit ada hier da punkt nee nee kein punkt pfeil mit strich
Ok machen wir einfach select folder create new function app alles klar perfekt machen wir jetzt
Stopp stopp gehen wir wieder ins azure fenster und jetzt function muss ich jetzt noch mal ausführen dass ich das machen kann oder wie
Hier gibt es Sachen die muss man nicht verstehen ok execute function und jetzt und jetzt was das das da wahrscheinlich deploy to function app
Create ok was soll ich machen create new function app dont choose the advanced option which isnt covered in this article ok nicht advanced leute
Wir sind noch nicht 5 head genug für azure function wir sind noch noch 4 head noch kein level hier wir machen das normale
Ok enter global unique name for new function app 3 head wie das ist das ist moment 3 head ist wirklich global unique es hat noch niemand was 3 head
angelegt auf azure vorher kann ich glaube ich kann ich gar nicht vorstellen ok non non lts jawoll germany west das war es jetzt ok was was passiert
hier gerade ich erregistert providers ok also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich habe absolut nicht den plastischen schimmer was da gerade passiert
es ist zumindest langsam das heißt wenn ich jetzt in azure reingucke habe ich dann schon eine function die lululul 1 2 3 habe ich dann schon eine function die jetzt
3 head heißt ne ich habe noch keine function warte mal das kommt man sich doch hier einstellen irgendwo dass er das links immer einblendet
noch ist nichts da ah der ist ja auch nicht so schnell der ist ja nicht so schnell jetzt der ist jetzt ist er grad jetzt ist er grad beim deployen der 3 head app
doch nichts da also wenn der fertig ist und es ist immer noch nichts da dann stimmt irgendwas nicht ich merkte dass es schon vergeben ist ja das wäre es jetzt er
muss das doch in die usa schicken ja aber das ist ja nicht groß das ist ja das gute an functions nicht so dass es jetzt irgendwie 80 mb ist oder so es wäre cool wenn man
irgendwie so einen status hätte was der macht so ok was zum was macht der da immer noch nicht da ich gehe mal davon aus dass das nächste deployment
schneller geht dass das erste bloß so langsam ist erst mal fad berechnen genau das liegt dann wieder in leipzig rum wie mein letztes paket aus den usa für 2
wochen das war auch mein letztes paket aus den usa sag ich euch deployment to 3 head completed wollen wir mal überprüfen ob das stimmt da ist es leute 3 kopf da ist es wirklich ok und jetzt sieht man
schon dass das das ist absolut menschenverachtend dass es wirklich der unübersichtlichste shit den ich je gesehen habe es ist es ist so krass du findest
hier drin nix ok wo sehe ich denn wo sehe ich denn jetzt was der macht update web site web site in den locks ja die frage ist bloß wo sind die locks ne ne ne ne wo sind die
lock stream locks oder lock stream lock stream web ui alda genau ah ok macht jetzt was kann man der asia function manuell triggern geht das wenn ich jetzt
wüsste wie ich dem overview wir waren dann sonst aber er macht was easy also was macht er dann id 3 hat state das ist aber nicht die ausgabe mit
diesen 3 balken ok manually trigger asia function ja nicht manuel manuel neuer manuelles ausführen einer asia function ohne jawoll und das ganze ist
please auf englisch hau zum manuel non http triggert function weiß ich wo das ist keine ahnung functions master ja lull das zeige ich euch jetzt ganz
bestimmt im stream lull vergesst das machen wir heute nicht
wir gehen mal auf locks ok mach das video weg what the fuck ah was seh ich alda hat das keine konsole doch das hier aber irgendwie läuft das
nicht das läuft jetzt schon seit running also ich meine er macht ja auch irgendwas macht das mal ein bisschen kleiner grad es wird nicht es wird nicht
wirklich besser clear ok aber aber da müssen auch die locks auch drin stehen oder die pleute ist jetzt einfach noch mal easy ich schreibe
jetzt einfach wir machen jetzt wir ändern da jetzt einfach eine sache lehrzeichen da wollte ich immer lehrzeichen haben deploy 3 hat deploy ok jetzt
können wir gleich mal sehen ob das deployment jetzt schneller geht als vorher ich meine er läuft ja aber so wirklich mache tut er nix was reconnect
ach ist warum warum ist es und jetzt du du du du du du du du du du du du ok da bin ich da bin ich eindeutig zu laubrein für alda das hier zu
sehen dass das hier durch zu blicken jetzt auf was macht er dafür dinger massive inside alda informe ich der müsste doch jetzt auch die locks
ausgeben dass es am besten über log analytics geht ja das ist das hier log analytics ist das hier der läuft ja auch aber der gibt
irgendwie nix aus ok log analytics das ist das war was zum geier soll ich da jetzt machen ich will einfach nur die ausgabe
zu sehen go to application insides ok insides ok und jetzt
transaction search what the fuck das ist mir zu zu 6 hat alda log ist das vielleicht verkehrt
die oder doch das schon richtig
way too smart ich meine es scheint ja zu laufen sonst wird jetzt wird hier nicht laufen irgendwie seine ausgabe kommen aber muss ich vielleicht dieses run on startup wieder raus machen
war ja ron syntax
every minute sollte er eigentlich laufen genau
macht aber nicht
transaction search nicht live mittricks live mittricks stream is connecting
das ist ja mal big brain hoch hoch 30 alda btf auch immer noch dinger trace
macht es irgendwas
ok transaction search
das wegen geht das nicht es ist es ist es ist broken leute es ist broken mein korn ist kaputt sehr gut sehr gut zu wissen
übersichtlich ok warum warum ist das eine invalid kron expression das ist doch vollkommen ok ich mache jetzt einfach noch ein sternchen mehr davor easy und deploy das noch mal
und dann hoffen wir das funktioniert die hat wird die platt bäm
das ist microsoft konsum taks ja ich merke schon die ist advanced als die normale linux konsum taks
clear aber übersichtlich ist auch wirklich was anderes ich meine what the fuck alda so was ist hier ist es aufsteigen oder absteigend aufsteigend
live mittricks kommt man jetzt an muss aber sagen google cloud ist das was ich gesehen habe bisher auch nicht noch nicht viel übersichtlicher und aws auch nicht nicht wirklich
und jetzt die pläne ja 3 hat wird noch die pläne die pläne zu 3 hat komplett
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ich glaube jetzt habe ich komplett jetzt habe ich glaube ich komplett geprickt moment wie war denn die sti wie hatten sie das hier am Anfang noch mal so
ich mache jetzt die default sonntags alter ah so war es am anfang ne so war es am anfang
ok deploy jetzt nochmal deploy da fließt das geld vom konto ich glaube so teuer ist
es nicht zeigt man sieht man denn was es kostet irgendwo hier ist das kostmanagement jetzt
kommt erstmal kreditkarten leak so und wo steht es jetzt billing scope es aktualisiert
bestimmt nicht on the fly current costs wo steht das
ne unten
das ist bestimmt das ist bestimmt nicht so schnell im aktualisieren
wie kriege ich den jetzt hier ausgeführt meine güte event types ah wunderbar trace ich will
doch nur meine debug ausgabe angucken meine güte microsoft das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein so hat er jetzt was gemacht so das hier war noch die die fehler von vorher
warum gibt es dann nicht einfach einen knopf jetzt starten
ok ich bin da ich bin da ich bin da echt stream logs ist das gleiche wie was ich auf habe
ich bin da zu dumm für also ich habe wirklich keine ahnung wie ich da irgendwie die ausgabe
rauskriege scheint ja so nicht zu funktionieren obwohl das das beispielprojekt von microsoft
ist das geht ja anscheinend so nett soll ich
das mal wieder falls machen ja weg ja in visual studio code funktioniert das
hier was ahja gut mache ich mal lokal an
ich meine laufen tut es ja sonst sonst wird es sonst wird es hier nicht anzeigen log level
in information warning error gibt es nicht ok wir machen das jetzt mal anders wir machen
das hier log log error bamm oder was haben wir log log error zack
hauen wir jetzt hauen wir die error logs raus da reichen auch zwei ok deploy three head deploy
ich weiß bloß nicht wo ich die ausgabe sehe was passiert im output window was fällt
du genau achso das war was anderes commit id bla bla weil dem log war falses zum log
kann man da nicht was ändern kein schimmer und ich weiß dass ich das unten rechts sehe
aber das habe ich doch im web interface schon angeklickt das ist auch gar kein unterschied
der macht auch nur den browser auf vermute ich mal
ach nee macht er nicht
genau aber es ist genau das gleiche ihr guckt
ok ok ach so every minute was ist die richtige sündtags für jede minute
minute wenn die minuten eindurch 5 teilbaren wert ergeben alles klar also das heißt drei
drei minuten oder was?
Kron Syntax every minute
So witzig jetzt das Microsoft hier sagt es ist keine gültige Kron Syntax
Wollen die, wollen die mich verappeln?
3 head running, 3 head running
Keine gültige Kron Syntax
Warum eigentlich? Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn dass das keine gültige Syntax ist
So wir lassen den Gram jetzt hier mal laufen und ich guck nochmal lokal
Äh ja lokal starten
Terminal
Und so starten
Und gucken ob das jetzt every minute funktioniert
Also lokal sollte das jetzt jede Minute was ausgeben
Generals kleinen Dankeschön für den Sub, 13 Monate, huge hyper subscription
So der sollte jetzt alle Minute ausführen
Gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert
Und was, und was macht der Gram hier in Azure?
Gibt, gibt nichts aus, das hat einfach
Oh guck mal es ist, es ist broken, es ist kaputt
Was macht hier? Trace? Trace?
No job functions found?
Man das ist das offizielle Microsoft Beispiel man
Kann doch nicht sein dass der Gram so null funktioniert
Was ist das? Das ist ja auch total unübersichtlich
Wer soll denn überhaupt hier irgendwas checken?
Außerdem ist das public
Was die haben 6 Sternchen statt 5?
Wie, warum 6 Sternchen, doch hier gehts doch, es geht doch mit 5 Sternchen
1, 2, 3
Microsoft weiß nicht was sie machen
Microsoft hat keinen Plan was sie treiben, das ist typisch
Aber guck mal jetzt wird es jede Minute ausgeführt und sogar eine Error ausgegeben
Ok das deploy ich jetzt
Das funktioniert eindeutig lokal guck mal
Wir haben 15.14 und jetzt warten wir 5 Sekunden sollte es noch mal getriggert werden
So jetzt, siehst du, bam funktioniert
Ok, zack, deploy, 3-Head, 3-Head Deployment
Das ist das Microsoft Beispiel, da kann nicht, da darf eigentlich nichts falsch sein
Kann man hier diesen Trace Campbell wieder irgendwie clearn?
Kann man das irgendwie löschen?
Reset, perfekt
So und jetzt ist das Deployment gleich fertig, dann guck mal noch mal nach
Ok, completed
Ok, jetzt läufts
So mal gucken, also jetzt ist 16 Uhr, spätestens um 17 sollte es dann was machen
Das sollte jetzt ja irgendwann ein Error kommen
By the way, ich hab das mit 6 Sternen auch schon probiert
Und da hat es komplett nen Fehler geschmissen gleich
Moin ChainLore, so also 20 Sekunden, dann sollte sich das triggern
So, 10, so, nope, das macht einfach nix
Das hat einfach kein Bock
Ja, irgendjemand klorische Ideen
Also ich mein, wenn das minimalste Beispiel von Microsoft selbst nicht funktioniert, was
willst du dann machen?
Kann man den Kram neu starten irgendwie?
6 Sternchen ging nicht, oder?
6 Sternchen war kaputt
Oh, was macht man denn Null vorne?
Aber offline hat es ja auch funktioniert, das ergibt ja noch weniger Sinn
Also was?
Log Stream, das File System Log umstellen, das Dropdown Menü
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment
Aber ich mein, hier steht ja auch nirgends so was drin
Da müsste ja die Errors jede Minute drinstehen
Das wird einfach nicht ausgeführt, ich weiß nicht warum
File System Log, Up Inside Logs
Ah, das könnte tatsächlich nen Unterschied
Aha, klappt das jetzt besser?
Aber das ist immer noch nicht die Ausgabe von mir, ne?
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt nochmal hier Run, Run und Start Up True
Das sollte dann einmal den Kram wenigstens machen
So, wie Uploadet man den Scheiß jetzt?
Run und Start Up sollte man nie auf True setzen, Null
Stack Overflow Fail
10.000 Euro Rechnung
Eine wirkliche Ausgabe ist hier immer noch nicht drin, ne?
Clear
So, Deploy mal
Ja, dann sollte ich es vielleicht raus machen
Dann mach ich es wieder raus
Aber jetzt darf es erstmal deployen
Ich meine, wenn es Unpredictable ist, ist es durchaus okay
Ich will doch einfach nur, dass dieses Standard Ding mal funktioniert
Und warum braucht es jetzt schon wieder drei Stunden zum Deployen, Alter?
Okay, fertig
Aha, da ist es
Jetzt funktioniert's
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung warum es jetzt funktioniert und vorher nicht funktioniert
Aber jetzt funktioniert's
Okay
Was auch immer, ich weiß es nicht
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum es jetzt geht und vorher nicht
Alles klar, jetzt funktioniert's
So, aber dann ist immer noch die Frage, warum es dann bei mir lokal funktioniert und online
nicht
Dann wäre dieser Simulator voll für den Arsch
Aber gut, wenigstens funktioniert jetzt die absoluten Basic-Dinger
Er triggert den Kram hier, C-Sharp
Timer Trigger Function
Das heißt, es sollte jetzt in einer Minute wieder laufen
15.21 und jetzt soll es wieder laufen
Jawoll, passt
Okay, Timed, das funktioniert wenigstens schon mal
Okay, dann deployen wir das Ganze jetzt noch mal ohne Run on Startup
So, und jetzt kann ich das eigentliche machen, was ich machen wollte
Nachdem ich jetzt weiß, dass meine Azure Functions wenigstens ordentlich funktionieren
Guckt es euch mal an, Bäm
So, dann machen wir jetzt hier noch mal die Schleife wieder rein, dass man es besser sieht
Vor, 10, achso, woops, 10
Alter, könnte ich mal entscheiden, ob man da jetzt Tab oder Enter drücken muss
Achso, hört das eigentlich dann aufwärmen, wenn ich einen Error logge?
Nee, das loggt ganz normal, gut
Ja klar, ich meine, das ist ja keine Exception, das ist einfach nur Text
Okay, dann deployen wir den Kram jetzt noch mal
Und dann sollten wir ein bisschen mehr Ausgabe haben
So, und dann kann ich das probieren, was ich eigentlich probieren wollte mit dem Browser
Und ich wette mit euch, das funktioniert immer noch nicht
Ja genau, das habe ich gesehen, dass du hier oben den Kram irgendwo einstellen kannst
Genau, so ist das tatsächlich halbwegs brauchbar
So ist es tatsächlich halbwegs brauchbar mit der Ausgabe
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, also ich bin immer noch der Ansicht hier
Also dieses, das Interface ist, ich hatte auf der Arbeit jetzt auch schon ab und zu mal
das Vergnügen
Also das Interface ist wirklich sehr, sehr painst champ
Auf der anderen Seite ist halt auch wieder das, die haben da halt so viele Funktionen
drin, ich meine, irgendwie musste es halt unterbringen
CLI Tool ist auch painst champ, ja, wundert mich nicht
So, ist completed
Dann, dann zeig mal, dann mach mal
24, das heißt, in 30 Sekunden solltest du wieder ausführen
Lassen wir es mal auf
Ok, jetzt kann ich das machen, was ich eigentlich machen will
Also mein Ziel ist es, dass ich da drin ein Headless Chrome laufen lassen kann, der Sachen
fernsteuert
Zumindest ist es das, was ich für die Arbeit brauche
Das heißt, wir werden jetzt mal ein Headless Chrome da rein packen
Und keine Ahnung, irgendeine Google Suche machen und testen, wie das ausschaut
Fertig, das führen wir auch nicht so oft auf, nicht, dass ich Google beschweren kann
Wir würden Google, Google crawlen oder so
Ich hab was programmiert und zwar ein Tool, was eben eine Web, was in den Webbrowser automatisiert
und da Dinger macht
Ein paar Häkchen setzen, ein paar Buttons drücken und das will ich jetzt in, ok funktioniert,
nice
Das wollte ich jetzt als Azure Functions laufen lassen
Warum ist es übrigens nur eine Zeile?
Warum ist es jetzt nur eine Zeile?
Eigentlich, eigentlich sollte das jetzt 12 Zeilen loggen
Ok, warten wir noch mal 10 Sekunden, was jetzt passiert
Das ist ja gar kein Error, das ist ja nur log
Außerdem hat das eben auch nicht abgebrochen
Und wenn schon ist der erste Error, das hier und nicht das hier
Erstmal Schleifenextension kaufen
Ok, dann gucken wir jetzt mal in die Inside rein, ob es da auch traced
Erkennt er das hier irgendwie, dass es, dass es
Warum ist das nur ein Trace?
Warum ist das jetzt kein Error hier?
Das macht mich immer noch fettig, Alter
Ach hier funktioniert es
Hier funktioniert es
Aber im Logstream funktioniert es wieder nicht
Ok, egal, egal
Wir machen das jetzt folgendermaßen, also wir wollen ja eigentlich Log, wir wollen
eigentlich Loginfo haben, das ist schon ok
So und jetzt machen wir das mit dem Browser und gucken, ob das funktioniert
Ja 10 Zeilen, so ineffizient wäre das jetzt auch nicht
Ok, also jetzt muss ich einen ferngesteuerten Chrome da irgendwie reinkriegen
Wir machen jetzt was ganz Simples, ohne Fernsteuerung noch, sondern einfach nur ein Headless Chrome
auf und zu, mal gucken, wie viel Ram das Ganze braucht
Ok, schauen wir mal, ob wir das mit Rider programmieren können, das ist nämlich deutlich
angenehmer, als das mit Azure zu programmieren
Bin ich mal gespannt, synkt sich das, wenn ich hier Mist reinschreibe?
Ok, der checkt, dass ich dann Mist reingeschrieben habe, ok, ok, ok, das ist gut
Also, dann fügen wir mal Packages hinzu
Puppetier, das ist eine Fernsteuerung für Headless Chrome
Ok, gucken, ob die da schon irgendwas gemacht haben
Running on Azure, Support for Azure, ok, einer der lustige Bildchenposted, das lassen wir
gleich mal
Das ist von 2018, gut, das interessiert mich nicht
Sergeant Foley ist am Start, ok, das brauche ich, exellent, exellent, genau, das brauchen
wir hier, da
Azure Functions, perfekt, das brauchen wir nicht
Ich copy paste, nehme mal die interessanten Teile raus, sehr gut
Hard Functions, denn ein Headless Chrome Driver, angeblich, angeblich gibt das mittlerweile
Support in den Azure Functions, wo eine Deluxe drunter läuft, das kann man irgendwo auswählen
und dann soll das angeblich funktionieren
Habe ich gelesen, aber ich habe das gelesen für Node.js, ja, genau, den Artikel habe
ich gelesen, der ist allerdings für Node, deswegen denke ich mal, das wird mit.NET
auch funktionieren
Schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal
Die Musik ist mir zu geisterig, viel besser, viel besser
So, Downloads Folder, ja wunderbar, lockt das mal alles
Await, geht nicht, weil ich kein Essen habe, Task, nein, oh, go to, ok, zu welcher Seite
gehen wir, http://google.de und dann geben wir irgendwas aus, Page, ich gebe mal den
Source Code aus von der Seite, Get Content, Gets Full, jawoll, wir printen jetzt einfach
den kompletten Content, jawoll, sehr gut, dann sehe ich nämlich, ob es funktioniert,
ok, dann probieren wir das ganze mal lokal wieder aus, ob das jetzt funktioniert, also
der sollte jetzt von der Idee her ein Chrome runterladen ohne Fenster und den Chrome benutzen
um mir den Source Code von Google anzuzeigen, also den HTML Source Code, nicht dass es jetzt
irgendwie großartig super Test ist, aber wenn das funktioniert, dann läuft da Chrome zumindest
schon mal in Asher Functions
Ach Mist, jetzt muss ich ja Execute on Startup wieder machen, funktioniert es wieder nicht
So, machen wir da aus, ey funktioniert, easy, guck mal, Download, Moment, Moment, Moment,
Moment, haha, funktioniert noch nicht, funktioniert noch nicht, aber doch, hier guck, Google Source
Code, ok, das ist aber nur lokal bei mir, jetzt uploade ich den ganzen Kram mal und Leute,
ich wette mit euch, das funktioniert nicht, ich wette mit, ich kann mir nicht, ich brauch
ein bisschen kürzere Ausgabe, das ist zu viel, warte mal hier, wir machen das anders, HTML,
so und dann sagen wir HTML, nur das erste Zeichen oder so, fuck was ist das denn?
Konnte man nicht sagen, First, ich meine ich kann sagen Null, ok, führen wir das noch
mal aus, so jetzt sollte ich den ersten Buchstaben rausbekommen wenigstens, wo ist das Problem,
warum führt das nicht aus,
so jetzt gesagt Execute True, ich hab manchmal das Gefühl, das checkt das nicht so wirklich,
wenn man Updates macht, ich glaube ich bin zu schnell manchmal mit dem Wieder ausführen,
das ist bestimmt alles ein bisschen asynchron und wenn du zu schnell bist, lädt da noch
das alte, ja guck jetzt gehts nämlich, ok passt, das ergibt Sinn, das erste Zeichen
im Quelltext, im HTML Quelltext ist ne Spitze Klammer auf, was ja für ne HTML passt, hier
kommt das HTML Element, ok alles klar funktioniert und jetzt deployen wir das ganze mal auf Azure
und Chat was meint ihr, prediction, wir machen prediction, predict prediction, vorher sage
starten, wird es so in Functions laufen, Fragezeichen, direkt laufen, Fragezeichen, ja, nein, zack,
verstanden, gucken was der Chat prediktet, wie sehe ich jetzt hier nicht den Unterschied,
Equate, ah doch, ah der Chat ist optimistisch, der Chat ist verhältnismäßig optimistisch,
ich glaube nicht, dass es funktionieren wird, sag ich euch ganz ehrlich, aber jetzt können
wir gleich gucken, ok deploy, 3Head deploy, ja ich hab nur 30 Sekunden gemacht, oh, run
on startup, falls, ja gut das zählt jetzt nicht, das mach ich jetzt gleich nochmal neu,
aber wenn es läuft, also wenn es die Funktion triggert, dann sieht man ja gleich ob es geht
oder nicht geht, unabhängig davon, deploying, ja dann Azure, dann deploy mal, auf deploy,
lebe alles, de-completed, ForceChamp, ForceChamp, so, der hat es nicht gecheckt,
wo ist denn die restliche Ausgabe, wo ist denn die restliche Ausgabe, ich kann jetzt
gar nicht sagen ob es funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert, das ist nicht die richtige Version
die man da ausführt, oder, wo ist der Rest, da stimmt irgend, da steht, warte mal das sehen
wir so nicht, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat oder nicht, ja das ist da doch gar nicht mehr
drinne, das hab ich doch überhaupt nicht mehr drinne, ne, es ist nicht klar ob es funktioniert,
das ist nicht die aktuelle Version, weil da müsste Download Folder drinstehen, Download
Folder steht nicht drin, ok ich deploy das jetzt nochmal ohne was zu ändern, die richtige
3 Head Aktion hier, aber ich muss das hier vorne auf den ersten Bildschirm machen, sonst
wird das nicht aus, das hier live mit, ah, ne das ist wieder was anderes, Shutdown ok
jetzt hat er deployed, ok jetzt sollte er das eigentlich checken hier, so, ok in 90 Sekunden
sollte er das wieder ausführen und dann sehen wir ob es funktioniert oder nicht, 10 Sekunden
noch, ok, das hier ist eigentlich auch durchaus in Ordnung, ok, 3, 2, 1 und jetzt, Exception,
was für eine Exception haben wir, Error, failed, ok es funktioniert nicht, es funktioniert
nicht Leute, das ist jetzt die richtige Version, es geht nicht und warum nicht, kann man sich
die Exception auch irgendwie an, jetzt ernsthaft da unten und dieses Fenster kann ich nicht,
ich würde mir gerne die Exception angucken, darf ich mir die Exception bitte angucken
Error, ok, hier, da, wow, da ist die Exception, das kann doch nicht, wer soll denn das bedienen,
wer soll das denn bedienen, ok also was hat er für eine Exception, System Application
has failed, weil, process start, launch, ah er konnte nicht starten, der läuft ja auch
auf Windows, der muss auf Linux laufen, der läuft ja auch auf, oh Gott, warum führt der
den Schrott auf Windows aus, es ist kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktionieren kann Alter, wer
lässt sowas auch auf Windows laufen, ok, hat irgendein Mod das schon markiert oder muss
ich das machen, wie ist die Exception, ah du hast schon, ich wollte gerade sagen ich
hab nämlich gar keinen Knopf, so es hat nicht funktioniert, gut, dann wissen wir jetzt aber
schon wo das Problem ist, das Problem ist, dass der das unter Windows ausführt, er soll
das unter Linux ausführen, wie sage ich dem, dass er den Kram unter Linux ausführen soll
und nicht unter Windows, welches dieser 3 Milliarden Buttons ist dafür zuständig, dass er es unter
Linux ausführt bzw. dass ich die unterliegende Plattform ändern kann, wo könnte sowas stehen,
Overview, sieht man da irgendwie, Operating System Windows, genau, genau, das ist falsch,
das kann nicht funktionieren, Operating, Operating System, ok, haben wir hier Config, irgendwo
Configuration, was auch immer, Function Runtime Settings, General Settings, FDP, kann man nicht
ändern, das ist natürlich Sixhead von Microsoft, ok man kann es nicht ändern, alles klar, also
muss ich das löschen, Bam, 3Head wird weggeworfen Leute, Delete, Yes, Delete 3Head, Bam, jetzt
machen wir 2Head, ne wir legen 3Head einfach neu an oder machen wir 2Head, Hallo ich habe
gelöscht, das braucht, das braucht ein bisschen, wenn nicht kriegt das über Advanced, wenn
nicht kriegt das über Advanced, warte mal, jetzt ist es weg, Deploy, Advanced, 3Head,
Runtime,.NET 5, Linux, warum sagt er das Tutorial bitte nicht Advanced andrücken, oh
nein das geht ja nicht, dabei hätten wir gleich Advanced andrücken müssen, richtiges
2Head Tutorial, 0Head Tutorial ist das, ok 3Head gibts noch, Germany West, Premium, ganz
bestimmt nicht Premium, ja ja kannst du mit verwenden, ok, MinusHead Tutorial, ja ist
wirklich so, richtig brainless, ok nice, nice, what the fuck ist das, I try to run a Headless
Browser Chromium in Azure Functions and it doesn't work, serverless brainless, genau,
excellent.
So mal gucken ob das jetzt, ich mache jetzt keine Prediction mehr, ob das jetzt einfach
funktioniert, da ist es ja wieder, ey das Deployment geht ja viel schneller jetzt wenn
das schonmal da war, da sind aber schon abgecreated zu 4Head würde ich sagen, oh 10 Sekunden
Leute, mach hin, mach hin, connecte dich, wow, so jetzt führt er nochmal aus, bam, failed,
warum, warum, warum ist das wieder failed, Anzeige ist raus, yes, this is new Counterstrike,
console only, next gen, warum geht das jetzt nicht, warum ist es jetzt wieder failed, live
matrix, Zeichen her, warum ist das jetzt kaputt gegangen, Error, kann man sich das vielleicht
auch ein bisschen mehr anzeigen lassen als einfach nur Error, das ist jetzt ein anderer
Fehler oder, process create start info, C, Doppelpunkt, warum ist das immer noch Windows,
hat man hier irgendwie eine Konsole oder so, console, hat man hier nicht eine Deepak Konsole
oder irgendwie sowas, gibt es irgendwie eine Konsole wo man da zum Debuggen mäßig sich
connecten kann oder so, ok, ich werde jetzt nochmal gelöscht, bam, stop, yes, delete,
ok, ist es jetzt weg, das war nie weg, das hat einfach nicht richtig gelöscht, das hat
einfach nicht gelöscht, gefaked, was ist das für ein Shit, ok, warum ist das, warum
ist, hä, jetzt ist es weg, Microsoft, please, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein oder,
ok jetzt deployen wir nochmal, ich lege jetzt alles komplett an, advanced, 0w, größer,
0w gibt es bestimmt noch nicht, jawoll, dotnet 5, Linux, create new group, ja genau so soll
es heißen, Germany West, consumption, create new storage account, ja alles new anlegen,
auch das hier new, jetzt soll jetzt alles neu anlegen in der Hoffnung, dass es jetzt
eine Linux gibt und kein Windows, die Copypasta, die habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen,
never donate, never sub, neighbor, wifi, free entertainment, Bill lacht sich aus, ne, Bill
hat keine andere Probleme, da muss ein paar Millionen an seine Ex-Frau abdrücken, boah,
da war Twitter ja auch wieder am ausrasten, alter, da haben sich Mädels von Microsoft gemeldet,
die Bill Gates tatsächlich zum Essen eingeladen hat, dieser Unmensch, da war richtig der
Twitter Shitstorm wieder, ich meine das ist nicht die feine englische Art, wenn man verheiratet
ist sich an andere Mädels ranzumachen, meinetwegen, ok, ja, ist so, aber der ist der Empörungstrain
auf Twitter vielleicht ein bisschen fehl am Platz, ok, er hat deploit, ok, ah ne, er hat
nicht deploit, er hat, er hat angelegt, er hat, ok, Deployment completed, Funktion App,
bam, dann stehe Kramier zumachen, 0W GTKQ und jetzt, Logstream, kann man den Kramier nicht
ein bisschen einklappen, das ist mega hässlich, boah, du blickst hier null durch, ok, und
jetzt machen wir noch, jetzt machen wir noch, live, live mit, wo ist die Live Matrix hin,
gibt's die nicht mehr, wo sind die Live Matrix hin, ah, ah, ah, Post Jam, Post Jam, wo ist
der Rest, es geht, es geht Leute, es funktioniert, der hat einen Chrome runtergeladen und es
läuft im Hintergrund, es funktioniert, Pog, Pog, ich sag doch man muss Linux unten drunter
laden, dann läuft es auch, boah, das war jetzt echt richtig schwere Geburt, huge schwere
Geburt war das, nice, nice, es funktioniert, er startet einen Chrome, man könnte das jetzt
natürlich noch optimieren und den Chrome in irgendeinem Storage speichern lassen, dass
es nicht jedes Mal neu runterladen muss, aber guck mal, die Execution Time ist doch ok,
guck mal, der startet um 15.52 und er ist fertig, ok, Laufzeit ungefähr 3 Sekunden, ok, wenn
man das jetzt jede Stunde nur ausführt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich cold und braucht ein
bisschen länger, aber das kostet nix, das ist ja noch free contingent, ja, das ist nice,
das ist wirklich cool, dass das funktioniert, muss ich sagen, also wir können Headless
Chrome in Azure Functions ausführen, Poggers, so, und jetzt natürlich nochmal ausprobieren,
ob auch das Fernsteuern funktioniert, aber dazu muss ich mal ein neues Projekt anlegen,
das muss ich jetzt hier mal nebenbei ausprobieren, New Project, Console Application, was, nein,
nein, nein, hier, weiter, weiter Projects, ja, das gibt's schon, ich weiß, achso, jetzt
muss ich das Ganze angeben, Test, Kekwe, so, perfekt, ja, New Window, machen wir irgendwie
Desktop 8, keine Ahnung, ist mir wurscht, so, und jetzt muss ich nämlich mal ausprobieren,
wie man das Ganze Fernsteuert, so dass er auch was macht, wie gesagt, es ist überhaupt
nicht mein Ziel irgendwie Google Fern zu steuern, sondern was anderes, aber das kann ich euch
jetzt im Stream nicht zeigen, was ich da Fernsteuern will auf der Arbeit, wegen Credentials und
Login und Gedöns, deswegen probieren wir jetzt mal exemplarisch, wir machen eine DuckDuckGo
Suche, wir machen keine Google Suche, Leute, wir machen eine DuckDuckGo Suche, viel, viel
Advanster, Puppet, Tier, Sharp, jawoll, hinzufügen, yes, okay, das kommt weg, so, nach Möglichkeit
lasse ich den, wir sagen es auch keine weiter, nee, nee, so, okay, Assync, Task, so, und
jetzt seht ihr nämlich auch was, weil jetzt sage ich immer Headless Falls, Headless Falls,
jetzt solltet ihr nämlich auch was sehen, DuckDuckGo, DuckDuckGo, so, und wenn ich das
jetzt ausführe, Terminal, ich hab kein Terminal Plugin installiert, Boah, Boah, Monka, S,
was war das denn jetzt, was ist das hier, gehst du fort, Ygit, Ygit, da stimmt was nicht,
wäre es billiger, den Preis-Champ-Crawler so laufen zu lassen, nein, das wäre nicht
billiger, weil der Preis-Champ-Crawler läuft 24-7 durchgängig, für sowas ist eine Escher
Function wahrscheinlich nicht billiger, Escher Function ist so on Demand, kurze Laufzeit,
cool, und wenn du scaleen musst, wenn du von einem Request bis zu 100.000 Requests das
scaleen musst, dafür sind Escher Functions gut, Instant Arm, ja, Instant Arm hat sich
Eiple auch gedacht mit dem M1, oh, das war jetzt FireFedJoke, ich weiß, DuckDuckGo, Punkt,
DuckDuckGo, so, da gehen wir jetzt hin, so, und jetzt seht ihr nämlich auch was, weil
ich hab Headless auf false gestellt, jetzt machen wir das Terminal auf und sagen.net
.net, ach, hier oben, bam, guck, ChromeDuckDuckGo macht da auf, sehr gut, so, und jetzt müssen
wir gucken, wie heißt denn das Searchfeld hier, hat das irgendeinen Namen, ID, Search
From, Input, da klicken wir jetzt rein und schreiben CACV und drücken Enter, CACV, sehr
gut, genau das wollen wir machen, falsches Fenster, richtiges Fenster, also DuckDuckGo,
GoToPage, AwaitPage, Navigation oder sowas muss man machen, ok, das muss man machen,
AwaitForNavigation muss man glaube ich jetzt machen, ok, Page, Click, nee, Keyboard, Type,
so, Moment, nee, oh, wie ging das jetzt noch, Page, Click, ich muss das erstmal anklicken,
Click, so, Selector, dahin, Element ist das da, falls das überhaupt funktioniert auf
der Seite, so, Keyboard, Type, CACV, so, mal schauen ob das jetzt funktioniert, Browser
aufmachen, in die Homepage klicken und CACV eintippen, nope, natürlich nicht, das wäre
jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen, wenn das klappt, die Seite ist wahrscheinlich komplett JavaScript,
die ist wahrscheinlich einfach gar nicht da, ok, was habe ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht, Navigation
failed, because Browser ist Disk oder was, habe ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht, ah, jetzt
gehts, ok, nice, ok, Await, Page, Press, Keyboard, Press, jetzt Enter, ok, so und jetzt sollte
man nach CACV suchen eigentlich, ist es nicht Enter, Enter, Press, das kann ich mir immer
nicht merken, Pressing Enter Button, Quatsch, das geht auch anerweilig, Enter, der Chat
weiß es, nee, Return schreibt der Chat, der Chat weiß es auch nicht, Enter groß muss
man machen, Enter, man muss das eh groß schreiben, vielleicht machen wir da mal noch ein kleines
Delay dazwischen, Task Delay, dass er das auch gecheckt hat, so 100 Millisekunden oder
so, jetzt funktionierts, poggers, sehr gut, sehr gut, sollte denn ich eigentlich jetzt
hier wieder zu gehen, achso Await Content Ace, das geht ja auch nicht, by the way warum macht
er denn den Browser nicht wieder zu, unhandled exception, ok, weil, weil, warum macht er
denn den Browser nicht wieder zu, das macht er normalerweise, normalerweise macht er den
Browser wieder zu, wenn er fertig ist, hier ist er normalerweise durch, close, muss ich
hier von anclosen, ok, Closer, Close, muss ich das so machen, dass das auch wieder zu
macht, ok, von uns, sehr gut, alles klar, Await, wir machen jetzt noch mal nen Task rein,
keine Ahnung, er soll noch mal kurz warten, jetzt geb ich nochmal aus, Await, Page, Content,
das ist ja alles nur zum ausprobieren, so, jetzt kann ich klicken auf der Seite, jetzt
krieg ich das erste Zeichen vom HTML Code wieder raus, das ist auch angenehmer als Selenium,
ok passt, funktioniert, kann ich das noch ersetzen durch, Page, Await, Navigation oder sowas,
dass ich keinen Delay machen muss, ok, von uns, alles klar, sehr schön, das können wir
jetzt in unsere Funktion hauen, was bedeutet Await, wie soll ich das jetzt einfach zu
erklären, dass der an der Stelle, also bevor er mit dem weiter macht, wartet er bis das
fertig ist, allerdings asynchron, das heißt, wenn du das hier zum Beispiel, muss ich anders
erklären, mal angenommen, du hast ne grafische Anwendung, ja, und du hast ne grafische Anwendung,
da ist ein Button drauf, wenn du auf den Button drauf klickst, dann macht der irgendwas was
5 Sekunden dauert, dann hast du in der grafischen Anwendung das Problem, dass das komplette
Fenster hängt, bis diese 5 Sekunden Sache erledigt ist, so und wenn du das mit Await
machst, dann ist das nicht so, weil an der Stelle, also das hier ist eigentlich ein Return,
das hier ist eigentlich ein Return, nur dass er sich im Hintergrund merkt, wenn das fertig
ist, springt er hier wieder rein, also hier macht er eigentlich einen Return an den Aufrufer,
sodass es nicht blockt, und wenn das hier fertig ist, dann springt er hier wieder rein
und macht an der Stelle weiter, also das ist im Prinzip so geschrieben, als würde es synchron
ausgeführt werden, aber es wird gar nicht synchron ausgeführt, sondern es wird das
hier ausgeführt, oder das hier, es wird angefangen das hier auszuführen, dann geht man wieder
zurück in den aufrufenden Thread, oder an den Aufrufer, der macht weiter, und wenn das
hier fertig ist, dann macht er Continue damit, das ist jetzt in der Sache eigentlich ziemlich
egal, aber ich muss das hier verwenden, weil diese ganzen Methoden selbst mit Async Await
gemacht sind, deswegen muss man das hier so benutzen, gibt es sowas auch in Java, ich
weiß es nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung von Java, aber nachdem sowas ja mittlerweile sogar
in Javascript und sehr sehr sehr painschampig implementiert in C++ gibt, also die C++ Implementierung
ist wieder typisch C++, man hat versucht was zu bauen, was in anderen Sprachen gut funktioniert
hat es halt wieder maßlos verschissen, das ist eine typische C++ Geschichte, in Java
gibt es nicht, ok, ok, das können wir jetzt in unsere Azure Function hauen, so, vielleicht
sollten wir noch was sinnvolles machen, wir sollten noch was sinnvolles machen, wir sollten
nicht ausgeben, einfach nur das HTML, was könnte man sinnvolles, das erste Ergebnis
Leute, wollen wir uns das erste Ergebnis holen, wir geben keqw ein und dann nehmen wir das
erste Ergebnis hier, falls wir das irgendwie ordentlich cracken können, ich weiß es nicht,
ob das funktioniert, ich glaube in Javascript ist es sogar eigentlich ganz einfach, weil
in Javascript gibt es kein Multithreading, außer mit Dingen mit Background Worker, was
eigentlich kaum einer verwendet, was machen die Functions, Dinge ausführen, wie krieg
ich, wie kann ich mir das erste Ergebnis crappen, hat irgendjene eine glorreiche Idee, wie krieg
ich das erste Ergebnis hier Leute, Console, probieren wirs mal aus, Document, Query, Query
Selector, wie ist das, CW, ne, oder wie krieg ich das erste, wie krieg ich das erste hier,
Results Main, Results Main ist schon mal gut, Main's Champ, Results Main und dann links
und dann R1.0, ok, ich muss eigentlich nach R1.0 suchen, R1.0 ist das Richtige, oder war
das ein, ok, nice, R1.0, R1.0 muss ich suchen nach all die, ok und dann krieg ich, wie krieg
ich davon jetzt die erste, den ersten, inner, inner HTML, oh ne, das Parson, ich mach jetzt
kein HTML Parson, das können wir vergessen, das mach ich jetzt nicht, hier, Text, inner
Text, perfekt, das will ich haben, das nehme ich zum testen, oh mein Gott, Bill Gates persönlich
im Chat, hat er noch, Bill, Bill, hast du noch ein bisschen irgendwie Corona Impfzeug für
mich übrig, ich bin beim Impfzentrum registriert und bei meinem Hausarzt registriert und ich
hab noch keinen Termin, ich mein, wenn er das nicht hat, ok, das passt, also das da R1,
das ist cool, da sehen wir nämlich auch gleich ob es funktioniert, oh Bill ist schon wieder
weg, oh Pains Champ, Pains Champ, Alter, hab ich gedacht, könnte ich einmal mit Bill Gates
in meinem Leben im Twitch Chat reden, weil ich mein, wenn man sonst keine Chance darauf
hat schon mal Bill Gates zu treffen, ich mein im Twitch Chat ist ja real, wenn da Elon Musk
oder Bill Gates oder wer auch immer im Twitch Chat auftaucht, dann wissen wir ja alle, dass
das immer echt ist und jetzt hab ich gedacht, ich kann einmal mal mit Bill Gates reden und
das ging nicht, bin ich, bin ich Zedge, aber richtig Zedge, ich bin übrigens hier im falschen
Fenster, Zedge, Zedge, genau, also was machen wir jetzt, so, wir haben navigiert, wir sagen
jetzt Page, Query Selector, was macht denn der dann, R1, Element, ok, und wie krieg ich
jetzt den Text, Inner, Text, ne, wie krieg ich von dem Element jetzt den Text raus, boah,
Content, ne, ok, jetzt hab ich keinen Plan mehr, get text element, how to get text inside
gif, easy, easy, await, page, use selector, page, evaluate, ne Moment, ich will ja Puppetier
scharp haben, get element containing text, also Stackoverflow Beste, what, was, ok, ok,
das ist nicht valid syntax, das stimmt nicht, was die Typen hier schreiben, guck, das ist
nicht valid syntax, das kann nicht valid syntax sein, ne, ne, ne, ne, der Typ schreibt einfach
irgendwo, ne, ne, Punkt Text gibt es nicht, guck, ach, ich bin schon wieder im falschen
Alter drin, fünf muss ich, fünf, Text gibt es nicht, ne, ne, es ist ja kein JavaScript
hier, ja, element, hier, here, await, await, element, very, also, text, inner text, da ist
es, bam, das will ich haben, perfekt, das will ich haben, inner text, element, das funktioniert
jetzt so, da habe ich jetzt mal eine Zweifel, dass das klappt, funktioniert, es geht einfach,
es geht einfach, ne, ne, ne, es ist kein JavaScript, das hier ist JavaScript, weil du das im Chrome
Kontext ausführst, der Rest drum herum nicht, funktioniert einfach, ok, nice, jetzt können
wir den Kram in unsere Funktion hauen und gucken, ob es funktioniert und das ist jetzt
ein ziemlich guter Test für das, was ich eigentlich machen will, dann für die Anwendung
auf der Arbeit, wenn das funktioniert, dann ist die Chance sehr hoch, dass das, was ich
vorhabe, allgemein in Azure Functions funktioniert, ok, deploy, 0wgtkw, was hast du denn vor, ich
habe so eine Chrome Fernsteuerung auf der Arbeit gebastelt, die ein paar Tasks erledigt,
einmal in der Stunde und ich habe mir gedacht, wir lassen jetzt einfach in Azure Functions
laufen, also es ist doch ein bisschen umfangreicher, als, genau, das macht ja noch zwei Fakta-Authentifizierungen
und sowas und dann räumt das Spam-E-Mails auf und sowas, das macht schon ein bisschen
mehr und ich habe mir gedacht, man könnte es wunderbar in Azure Functions laufen lassen,
das ist Deployment fertig, Deployment completed, ok, in 15 Sekunden wird es neu ausgeführt,
kann das Captures lösen, nee, brauch ich auch nicht, aber es gibt Methoden, um Captures
zu lösen, je nach Captures, aber nee, das macht es nicht, so, jetzt, jetzt, zack, Start,
oder auch nicht, warum geht denn, Alter, Azure, ah jetzt, jetzt, es hat einfach 12 Sekunden
verspät, ah, das war Cold Start wahrscheinlich, das braucht jetzt ein bisschen länger, Download,
oder Download ist aber langsam diesmal, oder hat er jetzt abgebrochen, hat er jetzt abgebrochen
zwischendurch, hatte ich gedacht, leck mich, kein Bock mehr, wollte er nicht mehr, oder,
ok jetzt führt er nochmal aus, so, Achtung, jetzt, zack, ah, aus irgendwelchen Sekunden
geht es jetzt nicht mehr, ich weiß nicht genau, warum es jetzt nicht mehr geht, nein, nein,
der Chatplains IDE viel, viel nicer, ok, also, was ich gebaut habe funktioniert nicht, was
wahrscheinlich an irgendwie komischen Dingern von mir liegt, wir testen mal lokal, ob es
funktioniert, Alter, die Musik, es hört sich ja fast an wie dieser Ubisoft Flöten Typ,
kennt ihr noch den Ubisoft Flöten, tut da von der E3 von vor zwei Jahren, wieso, hier
funktioniert doch alles, guck mal, funktioniert doch alles, warum geht es jetzt, warum geht
es jetzt, sind er schon wieder nicht, Atlas gleich du, ja, ja, ist ja, wir können mal
gucken, warum er failed ist, warum bist du failed, vielleicht sollte ich es über Bing
machen, genau, das ist Microsoft, ne Leute, ich habe vergessen, wo waren das jetzt nochmal,
was ich vorher angeklickt hatte, hat irgendwer noch einen Plan, wo diese längeren Logs
waren, ach jetzt geht es, ich glaube ich habe eine Execution Zeit Limit, kann das sein,
jetzt hat es funktioniert, guck mal, jetzt funktioniert alles, jetzt funktioniert es,
ich habe bestimmt ein Time Limit Execution mäßig, das geht zu langsam, vermute ich mal,
aber es funktioniert prinzipiell, hier guck, das klappt wunderbar, so 16.15, jetzt sollte
es gleich wieder ausführen, ja, ob der Chrome neu runterlädt, das habe ich noch nicht so
genau gecheckt, da ist ja ein Storage drunter, ich weiß nicht, ob der Chrome jedes Mal neu
runterlädt, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Plan, das muss man mal nachgucken, ja guck,
da muss irgendeine Art Execution Limit in der Zeit haben, weil der macht das manchmal
einfach nicht, wo war ich denn eben mit den Logs, wo war das denn, Matrix, wo war ich
denn eben, wo man das alles anzeigen konnte, ich finde mich hier noch nicht wirklich zurecht,
normale Matrix waren es auf jeden Fall nicht, hat noch jemand eine Ahnung wo ich da gewesen
bin, es war nicht, war das das hier, nee ne, Insights, achja Application Insights war ich,
genau, genau, ja, genau, das Programm läuft nicht in der Dauer Loop, das Programm wird
jede Minute einmal ausgeführt, automatisch, so und da kommt man jetzt irgendwie Transaction
Search, nee das funktioniert, das funktioniert wunderbar, ja, einmal zuletzt ausgeführt,
aber ich glaube ich habe so eine Art Execution Limit hier, in was ich rein laufe, weil guck,
es hat nur funktioniert jetzt vor 2 Minuten, jetzt hat es einmal wieder verschluckt, da
muss ich mal gucken woran das liegt, aber das kriege ich, das kriege ich, das kriege
ich noch raus, ok jetzt führt er hier wieder aus und bricht dann ab zwischendurch und so,
das ist furchtbar Painz Champing, aber das macht nichts, aber eine Minute sollte so dicke
reichen, der braucht 20 Sekunden vielleicht, aber das ergibt Sinn, ok passt, aber prinzipiell
funktioniert der Kram, da bin ich echt erfreut, dass das klappt, das kann ich erstmal gleich
meine Funktionen wieder löschen, sonst kostet Geld, mal gucken ob es sich jetzt auch löscht
ohne mich zu jebaiten, das Microsoft UI ist wirklich peinlich, mal gucken ob es mich wieder
jebaitet hat, guck mal wie das den Delete jebaitet, der Delete wird einfach hart jebaitet,
hallo ich habe es gelöscht, kann es mal verschwinden, Painz Champ Alter, ok nice Leute hat wunderbar
funktioniert, zwar ein bisschen anstrengend, aber nee kein Ubisoft Stream, zwar ein bisschen
anstrengend, aber wunderbar nice, schön dass so viele mit dabei waren heute, ähm Richter
bestechlich, dankeschön für den Primesub, Leute schön dass ihr alle dabei waren, danke
für die ganzen Subs, ich habe doch ein eigenes Video hochgeladen, richtig poggers finde ich
bis jetzt, und auch gestreamt sogar, also wir sehen uns, ciao ab, bis denn, see you